Hey!
Heyo!
Sag mal, ist die Kackmaschine noch an?
Junge, es ist halb 10.
Du und deine Ausreden.
Sag mal, irgendwas ist anders als beim letzten Mal.
Ja, irgendwas, aber ich weiß jetzt nicht ganz, was du meinst.
Wurde ich es nicht?
Ja, ich mir ist ein riesiges Missgeschick passiert.
Und zwar habe ich vergessen, in unserer letzten Folge das Intro reinzuschneiden.
Und es hat sich dann echt nicht mehr gelohnt im Nachhinein.
Junge, wir haben 5 Euro für die Lizenz ausgegeben.
Ja, wir haben es für eine ganze Folge lang benutzt und dann in der nächsten direkt vergessen.
Es tut mir leid, wir haben es ja gerade hoffentlich gehört.
Hier ist es wieder drin.
Wenn wir jetzt vergessen haben, meine komische kleine Impro-Nummer rauszuschneiden, dann tut es mir sehr leid.
Genau, wir sind heute mal wieder zu dritt.
Yay!
Wir sind Hendrik und Kejan und Steiger.
zusammen sind wir akronomisierbar
der Amateur-Podcast.
Das ist eine miese Unterstellung.
Wir sind Folge 4.
Also 5.
Also nicht nur, dass unsere Zuhörer schon
5 Folgen lang
durchhalten, uns anzuhören, sondern wir schaffen es
echt regelmäßig uns zu treffen.
Das ist unerwartet.
Wir haben diese Woche wieder
GitHub-Stars der Woche.
Wir haben ein paar Themen
und mal schauen, wie lange wir
jetzt reden werden. Ja, mal schauen,
was wir heute ein bisschen begrenzter hinkriegen und nicht so
zweieinhalb Stunden draus machen, aber da schon einfach mal.
Genau, wollen wir direkt mit den witzigen Themen
anfangen, so als...
Was sind denn die witzigen Themen?
GitHub-Stars der Woche.
Achso.
Und zwar, ich habe so ein paar Sachen zusammengetragen, wir können das
sehr abwechselnd machen, ich fange einfach mal an. Und zwar
Unit
habe ich gefunden mit Y
vorne, IO, und zwar ist das einfach
ein Fork von
Unity.
Von dem Ubuntu-Desktop,
den Ubuntu jetzt endlich auch noch einstellt.
Wir sind das Y einfach vom Ende des Namens nach vorne geschoben.
Ah, stimmt.
Ja.
Unit. Ich weiß nicht, ob irgendjemand
sich freiwillig das installieren wird,
aber hier steht tatsächlich
This is the fork of canonicals
Unity 8. Das hat noch nie jemand
benutzt, weil es einfach noch nie deployed wurde.
Die Unity wird abgeschafft?
Die nächste stabile
Ubuntu-Version mit Gnome raus.
Oh, endlich wieder!
Also ich Ubuntu noch benutzt habe, hat er das Gnome
per Default und...
Aber nicht Gnome 3, jetzt wird es mit Gnome 3 ausgeliefert.
Aber mir wird auch komplett
eingestampft.
Okay.
Genau.
Wer jetzt also die nicht-originale
Unity 8
Experience, die bis jetzt noch bei keinem
Ubuntu-Standard,
mehr sich mit ausgeliefert oder ausprobieren möchte,
dann kann ich das auf github.com
unit-io
runterladen
und bauen und installieren
selbst auf seinem
Red Hat Enterprise.
Und das ist einfach nur ein Fonds von Unity 8?
Also einfach bloß das Projekt selbst.
Was nicht das ist, was in den Bund gekommen wird,
sondern was eigentlich
der Nachfolger von dem jetzig
laufenden... Warum will man das denn haben?
Weil man mit Gnome nicht klarkommt.
oder KDE?
Ich dachte genau, was man haben möchte.
KDE? Ich habe ja nie wieder.
KDE ist immer fucking hässlich.
Das ist aber wertig rein optisch hier jetzt.
KDE ist einfach nur grässlich.
Als ich noch Linux als mein First Class Operating System
auf dem Desktop benutzt habe,
da war ich auch immer so ein bisschen neidisch
auf die KnoM 2 Jungs,
weil ich KDE verwendet habe.
Warum hast du deinen Slowen genutzt?
Weil ich es altbacken fand
und das Zimmer verstanden habe, warum es einfach
Also ich benutze jetzt schon seit 5 Jahren KDE
und ich bin, wer ist, nicht zufrieden damit,
als ich hiermit genommen war. Stimmt.
Hendrik ist so eine schirrende KDE-Gilusoffigur
für mich. Das ist unglaublich.
Ich hab das vergessen. Wie er zaubert da
und wie der das benutzt.
Ich bin aber dabei, dass Hendrik gerade gut erkennt.
Die Deathsops und Activities fliegen nur so durch die Gegend.
Ja, da bin ich selbst als Mac benutzer sehr neidisch.
Aber zu meiner Zeit war das so,
dass BUM2 einfach
immer einen guten Support hatte
für den neuen tollen Scheiß,
den es da gab, wie zum Beispiel damals
als Network Manager, der hat er immer.
Und man konnte halt einfach per Wii
sein Lederan einrichten.
Was in KDE Ewigkeiten gedauert hat,
bis da mal ein sinnvolles
Budget entwickelt wurde.
Jetzt schiele ich manchmal ein bisschen leidisch auf Gnome 3
und denke mir, das sieht schon ganz schick aus,
was die machen, wenn es bloß mal benutzbar wäre.
Nee, nee, das ist schon super schick.
Was mich stört sind diese linearen
virtuellen Desktop.
Aber egal, wir schweifen ab.
Was ist denn dein Getaps da der Woche?
Oh, kurzer Sprung.
ein schönes Projekt namens
SuckJS, eine Anspielung
auf Mark Zuckerbergs Namen,
rausgesucht. Das Ganze
ist ein
Group Framework, das dich in jeden Scheiß
einfach nur Stories einbauen lässt.
Hast du das auch keinen Sinn?
Nein.
Ich finde das so großartig, weil
Facebook halt so eine harte Kampagne
gegen Snapchat fährt und alles von
Snapchat so richtig im Grund und Boden
erfahren möchte und halt
Stories in jedes Facebook-Produkt einbaut.
Das ist jetzt der Running Gag im Internet geworden,
dass wenn du irgendwie neue
UI-Updates und irgendwie neue Features und irgendeine Software
reinbaust, es müssen fucking Storys sein.
Und ja, hat einer eben als Java Script-Failwork
das gebaut, dass du
Storys
in beliebiges Kram reinbauen kannst.
Du hast verschiedene Themes, Snapgram, FaceSnap,
Snapsinger, also alles Wortwürde.
Aber
es ist einfach so herrlich und es ist
so bescheuert und es ist großartig.
Der Code ist grässlich, da will ich nicht einschauen.
Aber hier, was hat das hier unten gerade?
Next Features, AI, more AI.
Chatbots.
Ultimate Big Collection of Stickers.
Sticker sind witzig.
Die brauche ich unbedingt in meinem Editor.
Das Ganze macht auf jeden Fall.
Jeder Editor ist mittlerweile auf Elektron basiert
und eigentlich in HTML gebaut.
Dann könntest du ja auch noch Stories
in dein Atom einbauen.
Rette ich nichts von ab.
Dev Stories.
Das wäre nicht ganz cool für deinen Editor.
die Commits so opera.
Es ist quasi
LoL Commits plus.
Oh mein Gott.
Da müsste man mal was implementieren.
Aus der beliebten Kategorie.
Bau mal jemand was.
Und zwar hätte ich gerne
als Atom oder Visual Studio Code
Update oder Addon
Stories
mit LoL Commits.
Die jedes Mal,
und zwar jedes Mal, wenn ich auf Bild
drücke. Eigentlich möchte ich nicht das Bild sehen von mir,
wenn ich ein Commit absetze,
weil dann bin ich meistens relativ zufrieden.
Sondern ich möchte das Gesicht
von mir aufgezeichnet bekommen,
wenn ich auf ein Bild drücke oder auf Compile drücke,
weil dann ziehe ich meistens so ein...
Es gibt ja noch so einen Abklatsch von Loicomits,
der macht einen... Also, wir können überhaupt nicht kennen,
was Loicomits ist. Loicomits ist
ein Skript, ein Commit-Hook, den du dir
in dein
GZ-Appro-Repo einbauen kannst.
Das macht einfach mit deiner Webcam ein Foto von dir, wenn ein Commit
passt. Und overlayt die Commit-Message auf das Bild noch.
Und wenn du möchtest, postet er sogar direkt auf Twitter.
Das habe ich mal Zeit lang gemacht.
Da gibt es einen schönen Account.
LOLKillian heißt er, glaube ich.
Ich glaube, der heißt LOLKillian.
Aber es gibt einen Apport von LOLKillian.
Der macht ein Foto von dir,
wenn deine Tests fehlen.
Das finde ich auch total großartig.
Ah ne, der Account heißt KillianKillian.
KillianKillian, genau das war es.
Heißt nur LOLKillian.
Also ist nicht mehr aktuell.
Oh, der letzte LOLKillian ist sogar nicht ich.
Sondern, hey Ben,
Du hörst das ja.
Muss man wieder anmachen.
Oh ja, ganz schrecklich hier.
Das Problem ist, ich hatte das auch mit,
da war ich gerade beim Friseur, wahrscheinlich sieht man den Übergang sogar.
Ja, da, lange Haare, kurze Haare.
Ich habe gerade die fürchterliche Idee,
dass ich das mal heimlich einem meiner Kollegen
installieren könnte. Das kriegt man aber mit.
Das Problem an Neukommits ist, es kann wegforken
im Hintergrund, dass er den Bildprozess
halt im Hintergrund macht, aber das kriegt er
irgendwie nicht sauber hin und hin und wieder blockt
ein Commit halt, bis er die Webcam initialisiert
hat und bestenfalls noch eine Sekunde wartet,
bis die Webcam tatsächlich ein Bild und die schwarz schickt
und tatsächlich blockt es dann noch, bis er dieses
fucking Bild auf Twitter geschoben hat.
Das war mir aber irgendwas so doof.
Das hat er nicht geklappt.
Das hat er nicht hingekriegt.
Wenn du es jemandem heimlich installierst, musst du ja nicht
darauf einrichten, dass es auf Twitter schiebt,
sondern musst du ihm das irgendwann sagen, hier übrigens.
Du hast diese Factory
toll, aber rein.
Database mapping errors, errors
everywhere, ich face facial palmierte
Also, Surf-Tipp der Woche.
Was?
Kier-Gummit-Fest-Eck.
Das war Trost.
Aber falls irgendwann wieder kommt, dann kommt es da.
Nee, Suck.js.
Das war mein GitHub-Start.
Ich habe auch nicht geschaut,
es gibt noch kein Atom-Plugin, was das macht.
Ich hätte kurz erwartet, dass es Stories für Atom schon gibt,
aber es gibt es noch nicht, so weit ich sehen kann.
Also nochmal wirklich, ich möchte,
wenn ich auf Copile drücke oder wenn meine
Builds fehlen, eigentlich bei beidem,
Wenn ich mitmache, meinetwegen.
Und dann möchte ich bitte jeden Tag
zusammengefasst kriegen, so eine Story.
Und da solltest du mir eine Story
generieren mit jedem Arbeitstag.
Ich meine, das ist doch echt machbar.
Das ist doch kein Rocket Surgery.
Das ist kein Zerrmärk.
Rocket Surgery.
Okay, wir haben noch was.
Und zwar hat irgendjemand auf Hacker News
einen Wim-Klatsch gebaut.
Das ist so schön.
Wim-Klatsch ist im Prinzip
umschalten für Wim, also zwischen
Edit und Command-Mode
mit einem
USB-Fußpedal.
Es ist so schön.
Die Idee ist, du drückst auf das Fußpedal und er sendet ein I
und wenn du wieder loslässt, sendet er ein Escape.
Und du hast das so lange,
so lange runterhältst du im Edit-Mode.
So herrlich, warum gibt es das noch nicht?
Es ist wirklich etwas.
Warum musste man das selber bauen? Warum muss einer erst auf die Idee kommen?
Die will klatschen.
Das ist super geil, ne?
Du kannst irgendwie eine alte Tastatur auseinandernehmen
und das damit bauen, oder?
Ich glaube, er hat das Selbstding
zusammengelötet hier.
Ah ja.
Das Problem an solchen Hardware-GitHub-Projekten,
also es ist auf GitHub, aber es ist eigentlich ein Hardware-Projekt,
das Problem ist, ich kann es nicht einfach klonen und benutzen.
Es hat eine Readme und vier Bilder, das war das Repo.
Ich muss es selbst bauen.
Quatsch.
Aber er könnte zumindest irgendwie
die Sketches für den Chip,
wenn er den selbst gebaut hat,
obwohl er wahrscheinlich überhaupt nicht mehr...
Egal. Quatsch, Quatsch, ich bullshitter rum.
Ich habe gerade dir deinen GitHub-Star geklaut.
hier aus dem Pad übrigens. Das ist egal. Dafür darfst du
was zu einem von meinen erzählen.
Ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne.
Ich hab noch ein extra.
Ja. Also was man noch erzählen könnte,
ich hab jetzt natürlich mal einen neuen Jabber-Client ausprobiert,
der heißt Dino.
Die Screenshots sahen sehr
vielversprechend aus,
sieht echt schick aus, er kann angeblich auch sehr viele
XEPs und Omemo.
Vor allem das Projekt lebt seit Februar.
Es lebt seit Februar, es ist basiert auf
GTK und Vala.
Leider ist Vala eine
Compile-to-C-Sprache. Als ich es ausprobiert habe,
ist es sofort gesackt worden. Das heißt, ich habe es nicht wirklich ausprobiert.
Aber es sieht mega viel
verschwunden aus. Aber unser Kumpel Jörg,
hat das direkt auf
NixOS gepackagt
und ist wohl sehr happy damit.
Also es fehlen
noch ein paar Dinge, so wie ich das sehen konnte, aber
sie kümmern sich echt darum, gerade
die wichtigen XEPs reinzumachen.
Sie haben
eine Vala XMPP-Library
entwickelt.
Die liegt da mit drin.
Weil die haben das XMPP direkt auch in Fahler geschrieben?
Soweit ich weiß, ja.
Das ist jetzt, wo eigentlich alle
Gnome-Projekte und GTK-Projekte
langsam auf Rast umschalten.
Vielleicht irgendwann.
Aber wir haben da halt schon alles Wichtige drin.
Message-Cardons sind schon drin,
aber sie gehen halt wirklich
in die richtige Richtung. Und allein die Tatsache,
dass ein Projekt, was seit Februar lebt
und im April, jetzt sind wir an diesem Punkt,
wo es aktuell ist und es kann bereits
um Memo, es sieht schick aus,
es funktioniert,
Nice.
Wie heißen die, wenn du
verschiedene Ressourcen gleichzeitig
online bist?
Ressourcen?
Das zeigt dir auch an.
Sie kann echt recht.
Kannst du noch mal kurz was zu Omeemo sagen?
Omeemo ist quasi
die Axolotl
Das neue Rote, ja.
Das ist das
Kryptoverfahren oder Protokoll,
was Signal geprägt hat.
Und das funktioniert dann von
Client zu Client.
Und vor allem auch mit den Mobile-Clients, die halt nicht immer online sind.
Oder nicht immer, mit OTR
musst du ja immer wieder erstmal einen Handcheck machen.
Und das ist ein Session-basierter
und Axolotl macht schon mal
von vornherein schon mal 100
Keys, die du zufällig benutzt.
Also es ist quasi so eine One-Round-Trip
Continue
Encryption, wo einfach quasi
die Krypto schon so ein bisschen
in den Bereich.
Wir bewegen uns hier gerade wieder in den Bereichen.
Das ist technisch gefährlich.
Ja, aber so eine Art.
Ich habe jetzt noch was gesagt.
Das ist übrigens von Naje Gulscher mit.
Dem Conversations-Typ.
Der hat das mit dem Memo gebaut.
Ja, genau.
Ich habe auch schon vor Jahren gesagt,
das Kryptoverfahren von Signal ist echt schön.
Das müsste man mal in XPP bauen.
Das sind Conversations-Typ.
Und in WhatsApp.
Ich habe jetzt alte Schulfreunde-Videos getroffen,
die mir gesagt haben,
wir benutzen jetzt kein Prima mehr.
Da bin ich jetzt auf Telegram.
übergegangen. Ich habe gesagt,
bloß nicht. Du hast übrigens
in der letzten Folge, kurzes Follow-up, gesagt,
auf Telegram würde ich niemals jemanden kriegen.
Zwei Tage, nachdem wir diese Folge
haben, kriege ich in Telegram
und kenne mich, Hendrik soll ich jetzt
testen Telegram.
Wir haben im Haus
so eine hausinterne Telegram-Gruppe
und die ist halt schon da.
Ich habe dir auch, als du mir auf Telegram geschrieben hast,
habe ich dir auf Signal geantwortet.
Ich werde nie eine
vollständige Konversation mit irgendjemandem
außerhalb dieser Gruppe in Telegram.
Du hast mir immerhin verifiziert, dass du die App installiert hast
und bekommen hast.
Ich finde das so ein ekelhaftes Telegram-Feature,
dass wenn du dich anmeldest,
alle Leute, die deine Nummer haben, kriegen eine Push-Notification.
Das ist aber bei jedem das im Genre so.
Ich habe das Signal auf iOS ganz sicher nicht.
Das ist ja schlimm.
Jeder hat sich ein neues iPhone kauft.
Also wenn der Signal Android macht,
dann finde ich das zwar auch nicht wichtig.
Bei Signal kriege ich...
Kilian ist bei Signal, sag Hi.
Ich sag hey.
Ich könnte mich gerade nicht entscheiden.
Ich wollte hallo sagen,
das ist mir im letzten Moment eingefallen,
dass es hey heißt.
Aber so ist es zumindest.
Jetzt gibt es irgendwie noch einen neuen Messenger,
der wurde heute, von ihr hört wahrscheinlich letzte Woche,
auf Hacker News gepostet.
Oh, die Seite ist gerade kaputt.
Die wird gerade ein Hack of Death.
Oh ja, die wird irgendwie gerade
offenbar geslashed.
Geslashed, so ist das ja mal stimmt.
Der Messenger heißt Token.
Ich würde gerne mehr dazu erzählen,
aber ich kriege die Seite gerade nicht mehr auf.
Die Seite ist da,
der ganze Style ist nicht da.
Und das ist,
der benutzt auch das Signal
Kryptoverfahren.
Der ist gleichzeitig
Private and Secure Messaging App, steht hier,
ich lese es hier verbatim vor,
a user-controlled Ethereum Wallet
und a browser for Ethereum Apps.
Also ich habe Ethereum bis heute noch nicht
verstanden, muss ich sagen. Ethereum ist ja Bitcoin
plus, hier jetzt Aircodes
einfügen, Smart Contracts.
das letztendlich beliebiger Code ist,
soweit ich das verstanden habe.
In etwa, ja.
Also du kannst so Smart Blockchain,
aber ich kann mir darunter echt immer noch nichts vorstellen.
Smart Blockchain, pass mal auf.
Ich habe Bingo, Bingo, Bingo.
Drei Kreuze im Endeffekt.
Also ich möchte gerne mal jemanden in diesem Podcast haben,
der uns erklärt und den Zuhörern erklärt,
was Ethereum ist.
Hätte ich echt gerne mal.
Du kannst deine Payments von gewissen Sachen abhängig machen
und dadurch eventuell sogar wiederholen.
Ich habe es mal, als Ethereum damals
announced wurde, habe ich Blogposts gelesen,
die haben das erklärt mit, dass du Dinge,
also gerade was du mit Bitcoin nicht machen kannst,
ist, also was du machen kannst,
aber du musst halt mehr Infrastruktur haben,
ist, ich bin persönlich, also Alice will Bob
Geld schicken,
aber erst wenn eine Transaktion
geschehen ist oder irgendwie eine Ware
geteilt wurde.
Aber das Problem bei Bitcoin ist ja, wenn ich das Geld schicke,
dann ist es weg und ich kann es nicht mehr zurückführen, das gibt es überhaupt nicht.
Da gehst du ja mal auf solche Brokering-Dienste,
wo du das Geld dann hinschickst und erst wenn
drei Nachrichten mit ihrem jeweiligen Key signieren,
dann wird die Transaktion tatsächlich irgendwo getätigt.
Aber das muss halt über den Dritten irgendwo laufen.
Das kann Bitcoin halt von Haus aus nicht.
Und mir wurde erzählt,
dass Ethereum theoretisch solche Konzepte mit abbilden kann,
nativ in Ethereum.
Aber ich bewege mich hier wieder in Bereichen,
von denen ich wirklich null Ahnung habe,
weil Ethereum überhaupt nicht blicke.
Die Announcement-Videos von damals waren einfach so,
hey, du kannst ja noch so magical Musik im Hintergrund einspielen können.
Die machen so kranken Scheiß.
War das Ukulele-Musik?
Ja, oder so.
Ugo-Zähler.
Das war meine Ugo-Zähler-Imitation.
Die war großartig.
Zumindest ist Token auch ein Browser für Ethereum-Apps.
Ja, jetzt haben wir leider, es tut uns ja leid, von was erzählt
und können dazu nicht mehr Details liefern.
Aber die wollen ja Payment.
Die wollen ja, was die Namen brauchen.
Die wollen Messenger, der gleichzeitig eine offene Payment-Plattform ist.
Das finde ich eigentlich geil.
Ich habe mir, als du mir irgendwie 30 Euro, 25 Euro Fahrtkosten gestuldet hast,
habe ich dir einfach aus meinem Bitcoin-Wallet so eine Anfrage,
einfach den Code, den es generiert hat, per Signal geschickt.
Also so kannst du direkt aus deinem Messenger dir Geld hin und her schicken.
Facebook kann das ja schon, aber die sind ja nicht offen
und du musst halt Facebook Bankdaten geben und so weiter.
Ach so.
Also Facebook Messenger kannst du Geld schicken.
Aber einfach falsch.
Der larger Point hier ist, WeChat zum Beispiel macht das auch.
Und das ist unglaublich fucking populär in China.
weiß nicht, ob im asiatischen Großraum.
Und genau das will Token ja
machen für den Rest der Welt.
Vor allem aber halt dritte
Weltländer, die halt keine gute Banking-Infrastruktur
haben und vielleicht auch halt
Nationen wie uns, die halt generell
arm dran sind, was
neumärtige Technologie und die halt angeht.
Ja, in vielen afrikanischen
Ländern benutzt du ja dein Telefon wirklich, um
Geld zu übersetzen. SMS-based, alles
SMS-based. Das ist unglaublich.
Das ist einfach um Twitter damit groß geworden, weil ich am Anfang
komplett SMS-based war. Nicht komplett, aber du konntest
hast du deine 140 Zeichen-Beschränkung.
Die hatten sie jetzt irgendwie kurzzeitig
aufgehoben oder aufgehoben für gewisse Sachen.
Links zähle ich mir dagegen.
Links. Und genau, wenn du Leute
Menschen, dann kannst du plötzlich,
und dann habe ich dann Screenshots von so
vollseitigen
Tweets gesehen, die einfach nur noch
aus Menschen bestanden.
Und dazwischen immer mal so Antworten von Leuten,
die sich beschwert haben, das bitte auch.
Das Problem ist aber auch, dass Twitter
diese Menschen-Reihenfolge irgendwie
so ein bisschen randomisiert. Und du kannst überhaupt
keine Fels mehr nachvollziehen. Wir haben es komplett kaputt gemacht
mit diesem Update. Also richtig komplette Marsch.
Und du musst halt wirklich einmal neue Leute rausnehmen,
weil es geht halt so kaputt.
Und irgendwann hast du da 100 Leute drin und es stört keine Sau mehr,
die da antwortet und du bist einfach super am Arsch.
Haben sie das auch mal wieder zurückgerollt?
Ich weiß, aktuellen Schaus kenne ich nicht.
Wie sieht es denn eigentlich mit Dritter aus?
Den ging es ja kürzlich gar nicht so gut.
Den geht es noch nie gut.
Die haben noch nie schwarze Zahlen geschrieben, oder?
Nee, also das war mir auch bewusst, dass die noch nie schwarze Zahlen
geschrieben haben. Aber letztens kocht er das mal wieder so hoch
Und dann hatte ich den Eindruck, oh, das wird wohl jetzt richtig drin bei Twitter.
Dann war immer so der Autor, ja, die hauen richtig viel Engineering-Work dort rein
und bauen ihre API besser und machen das alles besser.
Dann habe ich so etwas wie, ja, 100 Leute antworten, es geht komplett durcheinander,
du hast keinen Kontext mehr, es ist einfach nur noch absolut kass.
Die wissen halt selber nicht wirklich, wie sie mit ihrer Plattform umgehen können.
Die haben ein riesiges Harassment-Problem, dass sie einfach noch nie angegangen sind.
noch vor kurzem? Ja, wir sind ein Typen,
der immer seine ganzen Tweets mit
Sad beendet.
Das ist auch so ein Rassment.
Das ist Rassment.
Oder vielleicht macht der Rassment, ich check die Kontext nicht.
Das wäre jetzt der ideale Zeitpunkt, um Twitter
zu ditchen und einfach mal was Neues zu machen.
Warum macht das denn niemand?
Was haben sie heute gemacht?
Plötzlich Mastodon.
Schön. Das ist ein tolles Projekt, ja.
Ich kann nicht viel davon
erzählen, außer dass es
was das Grobe ist.
Ich nutze es ein wenig.
Es ist ein Twitter-Ersatz von einem Typen geschrieben,
der sehr viel Wert auf tolle Details legt.
Das Ganze ist federated.
Das heißt, es gibt verschiedene Instanzen.
Es ist eine Implementierung von GnuSocial.
Was ist GnuSocial?
GnuSocial sieht auf den ersten Blick eigentlich aus wie Twitter.
Ist das eine Plattform?
Ist das ein Protokoll?
Ist das ein Standard für irgendwas?
Also, nee, anders.
Mastodon sieht auf den ersten Blick aus wie Twitter.
Mastodon ist quasi eine Implementierung von GnuSocial.
Das ist so eine Art Protokollsammlung, um soziale Netzwerke zu bauen,
die dann unabhängig voneinander implementiert sein können,
aber miteinander sprechen können.
Die Standardimplementierung davon oder Referenzimplementierung davon
ist übrigens GNU Social.
Das benutzt aber keiner, weil es den relativ unpopulären Namen GNU trägt.
Die haben aber die coole Domain GNU.io dafür verwendet.
Die Referenzimplementierung davon ist in Twitter geschrieben.
In Twitter?
Ach, kannst du, ist in PHP geschrieben.
Ist in PHP geschrieben.
Und du kannst
so Sachen machen können wie
Nachrichten und Status-Updates
via XMPP,
also Jabber, publishen können.
Du kannst subscriben via Jabber,
du kannst subscriben via
Pubsub, Hubbub, du kannst
subscriben via Atom und so weiter und so fort.
Sind da eigentlich andere Dinge,
die Google Social implementieren oder ist da jetzt
einfach das Größte bisher gekannte?
Offenbar ist
machst du dann erstmal das größte, weil ich bekannte.
Ich habe mir irgendwann einen Vortrag vorgeräumtet
über XMPP-basierte
Social Network
Experimentierung. Da gab es,
die waren alle
halb gar und kacke,
aber konnten teilweise
untereinander
kommunizieren, weil sie halt bestimmte
XEPs und Jabber-Erweiterungen benutzt
haben, wie
Benutzerprofile. Im Prinzip ist ja
deine Jabber-Kontaktliste
so eine Art Freundesliste, die du sortieren kannst.
dann kannst du halt bei Jabber
nicht nur Nachrichten hin und her schicken, sondern auch
Statusnachrichten verteilen
und du kannst andere Arten
Nachrichten hin und her schicken. Das ließ sich,
wenn man ein Webfrontend oben drauf
gebaut hat, relativ gut
über
XMPP alles abbilden.
Ja, stimmt. Ein paar Bekannte von mir haben
in Dresden mal an einem Ding mitgearbeitet, was
auch nie so richtig aus der Tür rausgekommen ist.
Und das ist BuddyCloud.
Das sagt mir irgendwas. BuddyCloud, wenn du es heute
suchst, ist es, glaube ich, mittlerweile was ganz anderes.
Das waren so ein paar Hacker hier aus der Stadt
und vielleicht auf der Welt verteilt,
die für einen Typen so mit
so nebenbei das auch noch
gebaut haben. Da ist eine ganze Menge. Das war
eines der ersten großen
Node-Projekte.
Das war sogar das erste große Projekt, was
Node XMPP
verwendet hat, was hier Astro geschrieben hat.
Schön groß ist Astro übrigens.
Hey Astro. Astro hat da glaube ich
mitgemacht, soweit ich das verstanden habe, aber
das ist schon wieder gefährlich. Wir sind eigentlich
erst nochmal Astro einladen. Auf jeden Fall.
Ja, zumindest
wird das hiermit extended.
Oder vielleicht machen wir einfach mal auch Zeichnungen
im Haku. Das muss man echt machen.
Zumindest sieht Mastodon so ziemlich aus
wie eine Mischung aus Twitter und Tweetdeck.
Astro, bitte host ein Astrodon.
Astrodon.
Punkt Social.
Was kostet eigentlich Punkt Social?
Keine Ahnung.
Mal kurz zurück. Wir sind ja jetzt
in der Hoffnung, ein schönes
neues Microblogging-Netzwerk aufzubauen
mit Mastodon, was federiert
Föderiert, das sagt Deutsch.
Mit Ö, oder? Föderiert.
Föderiert.
Schön wäre es, wenn sowas wieder klappt.
Das Web aus den alten Tagen zurückbringen.
Das Problem ist halt,
ich denke einfach, es ist momentan nicht
an der Zeit für
föderierte... Aber es ist an der Zeit für einen Twitter-Nachfolger.
Wann ist es denn mal
an der Zeit für, was föderiert ist?
Das war schon vor 10 Jahren an der Zeit für, was...
Eigentlich ist ja die wesentliche Frage, was fehlt.
Aber ich glaube, das wird jetzt viel zu weit gehen.
Damit Leute verstehen, was föderierte
Zwecke sind? Nein, damit sie nicht das
zentralisierte System verwendet,
indem Mastodon Social
seine Sign-Ups beschließt, was es getan hat.
Und Leute, oh, das ist was Neues.
Und dann suchen sie tatsächlich mal hin und her.
Und aktuell gibt es sehr viele recht aktive
Mastodon-Socials. Woran es immer hakt, ist
das Verständnis für, wer hostet
solche Instanzen. Dann sagt man,
du kannst dann einfach dein eigenes Mastodon-Social
oder dein eigenes Mastodon
hosten. Aber
erstens soll das nicht jeder,
das hätte schon bei Diaspora nicht richtig funktioniert,
dann gibt es
kleinere Instanzen, aber dann hast du ja fast
noch mehr dieses
Bubble-Problem. Die müssen ja auch verbunden
sein. Nicht jede Instanz kann automatisch
mit allen anderen sprechen.
Im Endeffekt läuft es darauf
hinaus, dass du
Institutionen
haben musst, die bereits
soziale Knotenpunkte sind,
die das dann hosten müssen. Also hier an der Uni
müsste der FSR
oder die Uni
oder
der Chaos Computer Club. Es gibt ja
bei Jabba Servern,
benutzen halt fast auch alle den vom Chaos Computer Club.
Genau, das muss man nicht gerade aussagen.
Das Problem ist, XMPP,
Jabba, das war damals
der Renner, als wir
alle noch ICQ genutzt haben und es war verteilt
und jeder konnte seinen eigenen Server betreiben.
Aber das Problem ist, wer installiert sich für einen Server
und alle sind am Ende zu
Swiss IM
gegangen? Swiss Jabba, ja.
Oder beim CCC
in Berlin genannt hat. Oder
Schoko-Keks.org. Und haben im Prinzip
deren Infrastruktur heute. Aber wenn wir
uns mal umschauen, wo es sowas
geht, das ist das BitTorrent.
BitTorrent ist so,
dass es halt wirklich so Peer-to-Peer ist.
Das heißt, ich muss mir keinen eigenen Server
installieren. Du bist ja so.
Wenn ich das Programm starte,
dann bin ich
das alles. Das hatten wir schon letztes Mal.
Es gibt ja auch BitTorrent-basierte
Messenger. Aber so ein Messenger ist halt
ein One-off-Ding. Da muss ich bloß deine Adresse kennen
Und dann kann ich dir halt Nachrichten schicken und die kommen an.
Okay, das lässt sich aber nicht auf ein soziales Netzwerk abwählen.
Dann möchtest du Statusnachrichten schicken,
die Leute morgen und übermorgen in fünf Wochen noch lesen und kommentieren können.
Wir wissen eigentlich mit dem einen federierten Netzwerk,
was das Größte mit Abstand ist und immer noch läuft und schon immer lief, E-Mail.
Die Leute flocken natürlich zu den großen Notes, Gmail und sonst was,
aber es klappt ja trotzdem.
Aber es ist genau das soziale Netzwerk auf E-Mail-Basis.
Emotion.
Die ganze Deutsche Post zurück.
Ah, die E-Mail.
Nein, eigentlich wollte ich gar nicht
auf das konkrete
BitTorrent-System
ansprechen, sondern ich wollte einfach nur
darauf hinweisen, dass bei BitTorrent
jeder gleichzeitig
seine eigene Instanz ist.
Jeder ist richtig Teil des Netzwerkes
als Client und als Server,
was ja auch bei den Social,
GNU-Social-Systemen der Fall sein müsste,
damit sie sich populärer verbreiten.
Eine Abwägung, die es auch noch gibt, ist,
wenn ich jetzt, wenn ich mein eigener
Host bin und meine eigenen Tweets
oder meine eigenen Tools, wie es bei Mastodon heißt,
meine eigenen Nachrichten,
die auch noch gelesen
und kommentiert werden können müssen,
hoste mit meiner Instanz, was mein Laptop
ist oder mein Raspberry Pi oder
mein Kühlschrank.
Das ist halt das Problem, dass wenn ich
mein Zeugs offline nehme, dann ist es halt weg.
Das möchte ich vielleicht auch, aber vielleicht möchte
ich nicht davon abhängen müssen,
dass ich die ganze Zeit so Dinge am Laufen habe.
Bei einem Bitcoin-basierten System,
äh, Quatsch, bei einem anderen System,
was wir kennen, wo man
mehr Nachhaltigkeit
der Daten hat, ist wie zum Beispiel
eine Blockchain, hast du das Problem,
dass du die Daten nie wieder losfährst.
Wenn du einmal einen Tweet abgesetzt hast,
der dir nicht gefällt,
ja, Pech gehabt, der ist jetzt, wird jetzt
für immer noch mehr
und noch mehr drüber signiert. Twitter kann auch
keine Tweet elitieren, Pech.
Ja, aber das ist meine Meinung.
Da kannst du immerhin löschen.
Das ist mein Problem, was bei der Open-Anhöse
ist. Ob ich jetzt was löschen kann oder
ausblenden kann,
ist ja eine Frage, die dann
auf der Anwendung basiert.
Aber die Kommunikation, das ist genau der Punkt,
was du gerade gesagt hast.
Ich kriege die Daten nicht mehr los.
Und bei BitTorrent ist es ja auch genauso,
dass ich die Daten sofort verteile
und das System ein Auge drauf hat,
dass die Daten möglichst schnell, möglichst weit verbreitet werden.
Ja, aber es heißt, BitTorrent
sorgt nicht dafür, dass die Daten da bleiben.
Das stimmt.
Die Daten bleiben halt nur da, weil sie eben verteilt sind.
Wenn alle Leute, die das einmal runtergeladen haben,
gerade ihre Kiste ausmachen oder verlieren,
dann sind die Daten halt weg.
Es gibt keinen Single Source of Truth.
Aber ich kann auch bei Beton zum Beispiel
ein Passus-Dennis-System laufen lassen,
was permanent online ist.
Was du eigentlich möchtest,
dass du in irgendeiner Stelle sagst,
ich weiß, dass dort meine Daten sind,
dass Mastodon, was die Uni hostet
oder was meine Stadt hostet
oder was der lokale Mastodon-Verein
hostet, das weiß ich.
Und dann kann ich sagen,
ich ziehe jetzt von Dresden nach Bochum.
Ich ziehe jetzt
meine ganzen
Posts von Mastodon.Dresden
nach Mastodon.Bochum
um und
dann musst du vielleicht
vorher noch beim Einwohner-Welderamt
dich drei Wochen vor Umzug melden.
Und das dann dein...
Mastodon hostet bei Telekom.
Die E-Mail ist als
Microblocking. Dann kriegst du noch so einen Aufkleber
auf deinen Ausweis drauf.
Dann machst du doch ein Ding.
Ja, weil wir unbedingt...
Wir haben auch vom BND ausgestellt.
Ja, und du kriegst bitte
Nachrichten von, wie heißt das,
Briefe, Dingens...
Gott, ich hab das nie verwendet.
Wie nennt man Post?
E-Post. Nein, nein.
Nein, so Post auf die... Amtspost.
Amtspost, den Begriff sucht nicht.
Kriegst du halt per Microblocking, per Nachricht
von Finanzamt in Nachricht,
die dir halt als zugestellt gilt,
sobald du sie abgerufen hast.
So ist es ja bei der E-Mail.
Wenn du dich da anmeldest,
dann bist du ja quasi haftbar,
also was heißt haftbar,
sobald du dein Account hast,
gelten an dich zugestellte E-Mails,
ob du sie abrufst oder nicht,
wie so ein Amtsbrief zugestellt,
wenn er in der Briefkasten landet.
Also du musst dann quasi deine Mailbox auch abrufen
bei der E-Mail, sonst bist du gefühlt.
Wenn du jetzt dort gerade checken könntest,
ob das in der Läden nicht wird.
der Go-To-Instanz, weil die von dem
Maintenance-Massadon gehostet wird,
die ist ein bisschen überrannt worden. Der hat das geclosed
und es gibt eine Liste von offenen Instanzen
und da flocken die Leute zu sehr vielen.
Ich bin auf
dreien vertreten, weil ich mich nicht entscheiden konnte.
Kannst du eigentlich unter den Instanzen
miteinander sprechen? Ja, das ist ja gerade das Filmladen.
Und du sprichst
Leute an mit
at username, at instanzname.
E-Mail. Genau, wie E-Mail.
Wie Jibber.
Wie Jibber, entschuldige.
Eigentlich ist ja dieses JIT,
dieses Jabba-ID-Schema auch genau,
das kannst du auch auf andere Sachen betragen.
So Jabba ist oder nicht.
Das ist quasi eine E-Mail-Adresse,
deine ID,
dein Provider
und das zum Schluss,
was bei E-Mail noch fehlt,
ist deine Ressource.
Was bräuchte man noch?
Quasi ist E-Mail-Username
at Rechnername.
Genau.
Ich habe mir heute erst die History
des App-Zeichens durchgelesen,
weil ich meiner Schwester
einen Brief geschrieben habe
auf meiner Schreibmaschine
und da kein Ad-Zeichen drauf hatte.
Ich dachte, das ist auch bei E-Mail nur drin gelandet,
weil es irgendjemand zufällig auf der Tastatur hatte.
Es wurde ein Zeichen gesucht,
was keine anderweitige Belegung hatte zu dem Zeitpunkt.
Aber das Zeichen ist uralt.
Das wurde im alten Rom schon spekuliert.
Das Zeichen gibt es schon länger.
Es hatte bloß verschiedene Anwendungsfälle,
aber nie was Richtiges.
Wie heißt es denn jetzt nun wirklich?
Bestimmt nicht Klammeraffe.
nicht Affenschwanz? Oh Gott.
Appzeichen, Punkt.
Alles andere ist widerlich.
Mir ist jetzt übrigens gerade was lustige Zeichen angeht,
auch noch was anderes eingefallen. Da hat mich meine Tante
mal drauf aufmerksam gemacht. Es gibt
Chiffri. Chiffri ist eine
App für Smartphones. Ich lese gerade hier die Webseite.
Chiffri ist eine App für Smartphones, mit der
Sie vertraulich und sicher kommunizieren.
Dank modernster Verschlüsselungsstandards können
Sie sicher Nachrichten versenden, vertrauliche
Bilder, Videos und Kontakte und Standorte teilen
und abschörsicher telefonieren.
Das ist jetzt Krypto-Chef als Messenger.
Das ist, ja, die haben
so ein richtig krasses Stock-Image
mit so ein paar Leuten, die Selfie
voneinander machen, mit ihrem Logo reingephotoshoppt
da auf der Webseite.
Die hatten mal eine ganze Seite in der MZ,
in der Mitteldeutschen Zeitung, weil das auch ein Hallenser
losgetreten hat.
Schön fand ich den Satz aus
diesem Zeitungsartikel
damals, war
unsere Server stehen in verplumpten Schränken.
Da kommt keiner.
Ja, und die Leitung haben wir auch per Hand
durchgeschnitten, deswegen kommt wirklich keiner ran.
Die haben sich wirklich
Mühe gegeben, ihre eigenen Emojis, alles
auf Basis von diesem komischen Schiff.
Oh mein Gott, ist das hässlich.
Verplomte Schränke, Alter.
Ist das ein Scherz?
Nee, nee, die machen wirklich hier Datenverschlüsselung
mit 256 Bit IS
im
CGM-Modus.
GCM.
GCM-Modus.
höchster Schlüsselaustausch
auf Basis modernster elliptischer Kurvenkriptografie.
Die schreiben einfach hier die Standardsachen
in ihre Beschreibungstexte rein, damit es für
Leute, die sie nicht verstehen, wirklich möglichst sicher klingt.
Ich meine, die schreiben was
von Benutzertifizierung mittels Schiffregzertifikaten.
Das klingt natürlich ultra krass.
Was soll das bedeuten? Sie haben eigene
Serts und...
Sie machen ja scheiß es auf.
Ihr habt
selbst seinen Sert.
Haben wir eigentlich schon Schiffregzertifikate
ausgetauscht?
Was ist das überhaupt?
Was soll das?
Wie du meinst, ist das ein ernstes Projekt?
Ja, ja.
Ich bin gerade überrascht, dass es diese Seite überhaupt noch gibt.
Also es klingt halt einfach, als hätte jemand
in der SSL Bibliothek
aller Callbacks.
Der Shop ist auf meiner eigenen Seite.
Schiffreminushop.de
Schiffreminus-Premium kaufen eine Flat für drei Jahre.
Was?
Ja, also ein Monat kostet nur 99 Cent.
Ein Jahr kostet 9,99 Euro.
Was kriege ich dafür?
Ich kriege Krypto für Flat.
Du kriegst handgestrickte Krypto
von einem Sachsen-Anhalter.
Das sieht genau aus wie Krypto-Chef
hier.
Weißt du, was da noch fehlt?
Sagt James. Das Ding braucht Stories.
Ja, aber so braucht es Stories.
Die App gibt es anscheinend für Android,
iOS, Windows und Blackberry.
Das heißt, das muss doch irgendwie
ein Cross-Platform-Bullshit sein, der bestimmt ja
was passiert ist. Das heißt, das kannst du direkt
reinschmeißen.
Und es sieht mega scheiße aus
übrigens noch dazu. Ja, man macht halt
heutzutage keine zweifarbigen Gradienten
mehr.
Ich weiß auch nicht, wo man die App ist.
Für irgendein Design-Bashen ist es immer unfair,
aber der Rest der Seite ist halt, also die Texte
sind unglaublich. Ich glaube, älter als drei oder vier Jahre
ist es nicht. Unglaublich sketchy.
Also richtig, richtig sketchy.
Ei, ei, ei, ei.
Ja, ja.
Als WhatsApp rauskam,
habe ich mir auch gedacht, ist das sowas wie WhatsApp?
Das ist jetzt so, was ist das? Das ist ein
Jabber?
eine App, ein Jabber und deine
ID ist quasi deine Telefonnummer.
Das hätte ich ja mal ein paar Kumpels
an einem Wochenende bauen können.
Tja, hast du nicht.
Aber das ist genau wieder der Punkt.
Das ist halt Jabber. Jabber als förderer
Dienst an einer zentralen Stelle.
Ja, ich will das nicht mehr.
Ich finde es auch schlimm, dass man
alles, also das finde ich auch bei Signus schlimm,
wir wiederholen das gerade schon wieder, ich glaube da haben wir
bei der letzten Folge schon was drüber gesagt, dass alles
an der Telefonnummer angehängt wird.
Du setzt halt voraus, dass du ein Gerät hast,
wo das draufhängt und du machst es halt fest an der
Kack-Telefonnummer und es geht halt nicht mehr
weg davon.
Davon abgesehen ist es absolut richtig,
es wird halt Jabber immer wieder neu implementiert als
neues Service, der halt komplett zentralisiert ist und nicht mehr
mit anderen sprechen kann. Das ist einfach nur dumm.
Immer wieder dumm.
Ich stelle vor, jeder
Spaßvogel würde anfangen,
E-Mail neu auszuliefern mit einer
E-Mail-App. Ja klar, ich kann Jabber
mit Leuten auf der gleichen E-Mail-Domain
auf dem gleichen Server austauschen.
Spielt es eine Rolle? Die meisten sind eh bei Gmail.
Der Jabber soll einfach über seinen
fütterierten Dienst mit sich selbst sprechen,
wenn er auf jeden Fall war.
Das stört mich so. Ich schreibe mit so vielen
Leuten jeden Tag lang, die nur auf Gmail sind
und das ist halt immer wieder das Gleiche.
Ja, okay, pump ich mal die Daten alle an Google.
Ist doch total wurscht, wenn jeder, mit dem ich schreibe,
bei Google ist, dann könnte ich ja auch
mir quasi wieder in Gmail klicken und einfach
da weiterschreiben. Das macht ja keinen Unterschied.
Noch so ein Beispiel dafür ist eigentlich, das ist wahrscheinlich die Masche.
Du machst einen Kommunikationsdienst, wo du so die
fischige
Bedingungen reinschreibst,
wie heißt das?
Ola? Ja, Ola es reinschreibst,
dass du möglichst alles abgreifen kannst.
Ich meine, es gibt tonnenweise Firmen, die ihre interne
Kommunikation auf Slack machen,
wo die Leute sich Codeschnipsel hin und her schicken,
was wir übrigens nicht machen.
Das speziell ist drin bei Slack und
Codeschnipsel, wenn die dann den
Standardspruch, so nach dem Motto, wenn ihr
wegwut... Das glaube ich nicht.
Nee, das ist nicht wie bei Facebook?
Nee.
Das war bei vielen Sachen.
Also ich glaube, wenn ihr eine Idee
über ICQ-Unitent schickt, dann haben die sich
da die Rechte vorbehalten.
Das stand schon bei ICQ und bei AIM
in der... Zum Glück war damals Google
noch nicht so groß. Sonst hätten die das wirklich gefunden.
Lass mal das Thema wechseln.
Wir waren gerade bei Slack.
Ja, wir haben auch schon bei Slack.
Slack ist ja
eine
Elektronanwendung.
Was hat die auch schon in der letzten Folge
Wir haben über Slack gesprochen, aber wir haben nicht explizit Elektron angesprochen.
Heute geht es um Elektron.
Willkommen bei Akronomisierbar. Heute geht es um Elektron.
Hallo.
Jetzt seid ihr dann alle schon richtig unterstrommen.
Aber was ist Elektron eigentlich?
Kurz auf das.
Kurz auf das. Elektron ist im Prinzip ein Chrom.
Ist das hier auch so?
Ohne die Chrom, also benutze Oberfläche.
Chrom oder Chrom, genau.
Es ist das, was Chrome
antreibt, aber ohne
die Oberfläche von Chrome. Es sieht einfach aus,
wie du es möchtest. Und das
nutzen natürlich ganz viele
Softwarebuden im Internet, um ihre
Anwendungen auf deinen Rechner
zu bringen. Also hervorgekommen ist es ja aus Atom.
GitHub hat ja, also ein Typ
hat Atom entwickelt. GitHub hat dieses Projekt
übernommen und da irgendwann
dieses Framework Electron rausgeschnitten
und das jetzt weiter publiziert.
Ein Typ hat
Electron entwickelt? Es gibt immer noch
Das ist das war, aber der war schon immer bei GitHub.
Nee, der hat vorher
Elektron angefangen.
GitHub hat das Projekt übernommen
und da gab es einen wunderschönen Podcast
zu, ich glaube es war noch ein Changelog zu Elektron.
Oder Changelog zu Atom.
Gute Folge, würde ich empfehlen.
Ich habe, glaube ich, auch gehört. Ich dachte eigentlich, der wäre schon immer bei GitHub gewesen.
Ich meine, der hat mit Elektron angefangen.
Aber es ist ja jetzt nichts 100 pro Neues.
Es gibt ja schon lange die Möglichkeit
für bei vielen Browsern, auch bei
Firefox gab es das schon lange, den in einem Modus
zu starten, wo du einfach das normale
Firefox oder die normale Browser-UI
nicht darstellt, sondern einfach deine Webseite
randlos... Das ist auch was anderes.
Also ich möchte an der Stelle mal ganz kurz
einblenden,
dass aus meinen
sehr, sehr entfernten Erinnerungen
in Internet Explorer 5.5
das auch könnte. Dem hat man irgendwelche komischen
ActiveX-Scheiße. Aber das ist ja geil.
Das ist schon wieder von Krieg.
Ja, von Krieg.
Das Einzige, was jetzt Elektron neu macht,
ist, dass es dir nicht nur, also im Gegensatz zu
Browsern, die Browser-API
zur Verfügung stellt oder dass du über
JavaScript auf die Sachen zugreifen kannst, auf die
jede normale Webseite zugreifen kann, sondern
es hat auch gleichzeitig noch quasi das
gleiche Interface wie Node.js.
Das heißt, du hast da mehrere Prozesse
laufen im Render-Prozess und
den Hauptprozess und in dem einen hast du
eine API, mit der du
mit der einen kannst du
quasi auf die Standardbibliothek von Node.js zugreifen
und bei der anderen kannst du auf den DOM zugreifen.
Ja, aber großer Unterschied noch zwischen
Browser-Fenstern, was einfach eine Webseite
lädt und darstellt und Elektron ist halt,
bei Elektron der ganze Kram halt lokal ist
und der nicht Live-Dinge aus dem Webstuhl,
die App macht das halt.
Ja, aber wie das Internet hätte ich ja vorher schon machen können,
ich hätte ja lokal mein kleines HTML-Spiel
laden können und dann schmeißt
du halt Kommandozeile
Firefox, No Chrome
und dann machst du das damit auf.
Genau, also möglich war es quasi schon
länger.
Elektron macht halt noch diese
coolen Node-APIs eben mehr, also prinzipiell ist das ja
eine coole Idee und
eine recht saubere Umsetzung
zumindest von dem her, wie ich
das ganze Ding anspreche. Du hast ja in dem Browser alles
drin, was du brauchst, um moderne, multimedia
fähige
Anwendungen zu bauen, ob die nur Desktop ist oder
Webseite oder ob das nicht. Du hast
Webcam Support drin, du hast
Netzwerksupport drin, du kannst alle möglichen Sachen
rendern, du kannst mittlerweile Hardware-beschleunigt Sachen
rendern. Du kannst über Webstops
quasi TCP-Verbindungen mehr oder weniger
benutzen.
Im Endeffekt ist so ein
Browser, der moderne HTML-Standards
unterstützt, genauso mächtig wie
jedes Qt-Framework oder jedes...
Mehr als das.
Das ist ja bloß mit UI-Kram.
Das ist halt bei den ganzen UI-Frameworks,
mit denen du sonst arbeitest,
mit den ganzen
nativen Frameworks, da musst du halt alles
in C oder in anderen
Beschreibungssprachen oder in C++ bauen
oder in XML-Dialekten
und das
Schöne an Elektron ist, dass du Webstandards
verwendest.
Da musst du nichts Neues lernen.
Ja, außer viel Frontend,
JavaScript, HTML, CSS,
fuhr. Und das blöde an Elektronen
ist halt, dass du alles in HTML
und CSS und JavaScript machen musst.
Ja, und dass halt das Chromium immer mitläuft.
Das war ja auch was, was es bei Firefox eigentlich schon
gab. Firefox ist ja
aufgebaut auf Gecko
und Gecko rendert hier nicht nur HTML,
sondern es ändert hier auch
XOL, Zool.
Deswegen haben sie da so eine,
das auch mal ausgelagert, unter Firefox
läuft der sogenannte Zool Runner.
das ist quasi die Beschreibungssprache,
mit der sie das gesamte
normale GUI-Interface bauen, das heißt
die Tab-Leiste
und das Hauptmenü und die
Adressenteile, das ist alles in
XUL gebaut,
genauso wie alle Menü-Einträgen
und das geht halt zurück auf Mozilla 1
beziehungsweise Netscape 5.
Oh Gott, es gab noch Netscape 5.
Wie noch Krieg?
Ja, wir sollten mal aufhören, vom Krieg zu erzählen.
Ja,
Firefox stampft das nun mittlerweile ein.
Die bauen Xul
aus ihrem Browser aus und bauen ihr gesamtes
UI nochmal mit HTML nach.
Damit machen sie ihre Renderring-Engine halb so groß.
Weil sie
diese gesamte Sprachunterstützung
und Renderring-Unterstützung einfach komplett ausbauen.
Was ist jetzt das Problem
daran, einfach Anwendungen komplett
immer nur mit Elektron zu bauen?
Weil sie halt ressourcenfressend wie Sau sind.
Und die Ressourcen des
Nutzers oder des Endnutzers überhaupt nicht
respektieren. Also in keinster Weise.
Du bist halt bei typischen Electron-Anwendungen.
Es ist schwierig, Dinge immer auf Electron zu schieben,
weil Electron ist quasi die Runtime.
Und diverse Electron-Apps machen halt noch einfach
unglaublich viel JavaScript im Vordergrund und Bullshit,
der nicht sein muss.
Bei Slack, wenn du den Slack-Client nutzt
und mehrere Teams drin hast,
jedes Team ist eine einzelne Chromium-Instanz,
die am Laufen gehalten wird.
Und das ist einfach nur mega eklig.
Die sind gerade dabei, das ein bisschen umzubauen,
aber das ist wohl nicht so einfach,
so wie es bei denen scheint.
Das ist aber dahingestellt,
du brauchst halt trotzdem die Ressourcen
für diverse Chromium Instanzen,
was halt echt nicht sein muss
auf deinem Desktop.
Und das verschwendet halt echt
richtig viel.
Ja, aber da könnte man doch eigentlich sich eine
eine Elektron
Runtime installieren,
die dann... Auf jeder Plattform
und die läuft einmal quasi und...
Da muss ich mir jetzt zumindest nicht fünfmal,
zehnmal Chrome installieren auf meinem
System, oder?
Wenn ich mir jetzt
Was ist denn alles
in der Elektronanmitte?
Slack.
Und Atom.
Spotify.
Dann habe ich quasi für jedes Programm
nochmal ein ganzes Chrom mit installiert.
Chromium, ja.
Ein ganzes Chromium mit installiert.
Das ist schon ganz schön fett.
Dann könnte man ja einfach mal
das als
Bibliothek in dein System
installieren.
Das macht zumindest die
Ressourcenverschwendung, sprich das ein bisschen an.
Aber schneller läuft es dadurch auch nicht.
Wenn du es schon im Speicher hast,
dann findest du damit auch jede Anwendung,
die das lädt.
Aber eine Tatsache, dass du mit HTML, JavaScript und CSS durch die Gegend wirfst,
machen Dinge halt unglaublich lahm auch dazu.
Ja.
Wisst ihr übrigens, wo die Rendering Engine herkommt,
die da verwendet wird?
Geschichte.
Die Werdegang von WebKit?
Das ist ja Blink in Chromium.
Ah ja, okay.
Pass auf.
WebKit-Fork ist.
Also pass auf.
Blink ist ein WebKit-Fork.
Ja.
WebKit ist diese freie
Rendering-Engine, die Apple irgendwann mal
nicht selber entwickelt hat.
Es ist nämlich ein Fork von
K-HTML. Das ist die
HTML-Rendering-Engine von KDE.
Das ist ja noch ein User-Engine, oder?
Wenn du dir instead auf KDE oder auf Linux
den Conqueror installierst,
der quasi der etwas aggressivere
Explorer ist,
der bei KDE, die ja immer schön...
Oh, jetzt habe ich den Namen erst verstanden.
Oh Gott!
Der alte Conqueror auf KDE
war genauso wie der Explorer auf Windows
gleichzeitig Filebrowser und
Webbrowser. Du konntest mit der
gleichen Anwendung in einem, ich weiß nicht, ob es Tabs
konnte, du konntest zumindest mit der gleichen Anwendung in einem
Tab dein Homeverzeichnis durchstöbern
und Dateien hin und her kopieren
und im anderen Tab hast du deine
Netscape-Startseite auf gehabt damals.
my.netscape.com
Also eine lange Geschichte.
Ja, ich habe das Ding auch nie so richtig benutzt,
aber das war K-TML
und da steht jetzt in dem User-Agent
drin. Das String von KTML
steht, glaube ich,
das Geile ist ja noch, dass die Geschichte, dass in User-Agent-Strings
von Browsern überall Mozilla vorne
dran steht. Guck mal an dieser Stelle die Show Notes noch
mit The History of the User-Agent-String.
Das ist so schön,
diese Kurzgeschichte.
Ich kann sie mal kurz vorlesen.
Aber ich muss mal ganz kurz zusammengefasst,
es gab
den Mosaik-Browser
und die
und irgendwann
sollte der ersetzt werden durch einen
Killer. Und der hieß dann
Netsky. Nein.
Mosaik Killer. Mozilla.
Holy shit.
Ich lerne heute richtig Dinge hier
über alte Namens. Und Mozilla
ist ja gleichzeitig von Mozilla
dieses kleine grüne
Gekko-Maskottchen.
Von dem ist es auch auf
mosnet.org. Bevor es Suchmaschinen gab,
gab es Verzeichnisse.
Mosnet.
War es ungefähr gerade?
19, 19?
Ich muss dazu sagen,
da habe ich das Internet selbst noch nicht gekannt.
Das sind so Sachen, die ich mir auch als rückwirkend
erhoben habe.
Zumindest gab es irgendwann mal Filter,
dass die Web-Server
geguckt haben, ob du wirklich ein Mozilla-Browser bist
und deshalb dann andere Browser angefangen haben,
in ihren User-Agent-String auch vor Mozilla
einzuschreiben. Deswegen fängt heutzutage jeder
moderne User-Agent-String mit Mozilla 5.0
an. Und das noch bevor es
Netscape 5.0 gab, was ja der
eigentliche Browser war.
Nur ist es mittlerweile so, dass
k-html bei sich reinschreibt,
like gecko, aus Gründen.
Weil es einen vergleichbaren
Renderumfang hat, wie gecko
und die Web-Server, die nicht
extra Webseite ausliefern für dein k-html,
sondern du kannst dem das gleiche geben, was du auch
mit gecko geben würdest.
irgendwann kam noch Webkit
dazu und man müsste mal irgendeinen
User-Agent-String aufmachen, der sowas
verwendet. Mach doch mal bitte hier irgendwie
auf irgendwas, was dir dein User-Agent-String
Anzeige auf IP Chicken oder sowas.
Und da steht jetzt, dein
User-Agent-String ist historisch gewachsen.
Mozilla 5, Macintosh
Intel, bla bla bla.
Apple WebKit in Klammern
K-HTML, like Gekko.
Ja.
Da sind quasi fast alle Browser
namentlich erwähnt.
Das ist eigentlich heutzutage
irgendwer noch auf User-Agent-Strings?
Werden die von irgendwelchen Servern noch zerpflückt?
Ja, doch.
Außer Registräger?
Nee, für mobile Clients.
Ja.
Du bist auch für Metricant.
Wie haben die User-Action festgemacht?
Ja, teilweise schon.
Es gibt Dienste, die verdienen Geld damit.
Nee, also du kannst noch
aus der JavaScript-API kannst du noch andere Sachen nachfragen.
Du kannst noch Navigator.nale.
Ja, aber es gibt zum Beispiel,
das war HA-Proxy 1.6,
das ist ein HTTP-Lode-Balancer
und die haben eine API implementiert
von irgendeinem Dritthersteller
oder von mehreren Dritthersteller,
die tatsächlich Geld damit verdienen,
dir die User-Agents zu unterscheiden
und dann noch irgendwelche Metainformationen mitliefern.
Und wahrscheinlich sind die auch dann mit Vora von der Telekom im Bunde
und noch ganz andere Informationen über dich in Erfahrung zu bringen.
Das wäre das Letzte, woran ich arbeiten wollte.
Und tatsächlich gestattet er diese API zu unterscheiden,
ist er jetzt mobil, ist er nicht mobil,
hat er ein Betriebssystem mit dem Bug oder nicht?
Welche Seite muss ich jetzt genau ausliefern?
Also das war eines der ersten Programmierprojekte,
das ich je gemacht habe.
Was für ein Basen für User Agent?
Ja, und zwar
habe ich angefangen, einfach als
14-Jähriger, als 13-Jähriger
Webseiten zu bauen.
Und dann wollte ich dann
irgendwie wissen, wer mich besucht. Und dann habe ich einen
Counter gebaut. Und dann habe ich immer noch gesehen, dass es die User Agent
Strings gab. Und dann wollte ich da irgendwie
Unterscheidungen machen. Und dann habe ich
die mitgelockt. Und dann habe ich
für jede Zeile,
ich hatte halt überhaupt noch keine Ahnung,
habe ich dann, if String contains,
und dann habe ich
mache jetzt meine Arme weiter,
dann habe ich solche If-Statements geschrieben.
Und irgendwann habe ich mir gedacht,
dass PHP ein Execution-Time-Limit
von 30 Sekunden hat.
Schön, dass du beim User-Age
auseinandernehmend dagegen rennst.
Oh shit.
Vielleicht kann ich an der Stelle kurz anmerken,
dass die Programmierische Bruder PHP
genau aus diesem Grunde entwickelt wurde.
Was, um User-Age zu verflüchten?
Nein, um zu gucken, wer auf die Webseite kommt.
Also der Entwickler von PHP,
Als es noch PHP-CI hieß,
Version 2 oder 1.0.
Wie hieß das? Personal Homepage Tools?
Ja, richtig. Personal Homepage Tools.
Ja, Team.
PHP.
Personal Homepage Pool.
Ganz, ganz, ganz.
Personal Homepage.
Pre-Processor.
Ja.
Ah, sehr gut.
Genau.
Und ganz am Anfang hat dieser Typ
seinen Vita uns immer gestellt
und wollte einfach gucken,
wer guckt sich diese Seite an
und hat dann PHP entwickelt,
um das irgendwie mitzulocken oder so.
Und wollte einfach nur
eine ganz einfache Programm besprochen haben.
Da
haben wir das Zeug jetzt.
An dieser Stelle in die Show Notes sind so
PHP,
A Spiral of Bad Design.
Nein, A Fracture of Bad Design.
Ist ein bisschen outdated, aber immer noch ein wunderschöner
Blogpost von Evie.
An der Stelle hinzufügen könnte man
aber auch, dass der Podcast-Name Naming
Things für uns gar nicht mehr so
falsch wäre, gerade mit der heutigen Zeit.
Auf jeden Fall.
Tja, aber wenn wir noch mal ganz kurz
zu Electron zurückkommen.
Es ist also ein
sehr agiles Projekt, wo man
schnell, sag ich mal,
eine Webanwendung in eine
Art native Anwendung umwandeln kann.
Native, in ganz großen Anführungsstrichen.
In ganz großen, in mehrfachen, in dreifachen.
Du kannst mehr Sachen zugreifen, als du mit deiner Webanwendung besetzt kannst,
weil du die ganze Note...
Das ist alles anders als native.
Und es ist besonders ressourcenhungrig.
Im Prinzip tausche ich die Einfachheit
gegen einen enormen Ressourcenhör.
Und was kriegst du jetzt für eine Lösung vor, Kilian,
wenn du sagst, Elektron ist so ein großes Problem?
Ich habe keinen guten Lösungsvorschlag.
Ich würde hoffen, dass Leute Geld reinstecken.
Das ist für das Geld, gar keine Frage.
Ich würde hoffen, dass Leute Geld reinstecken
und native Apps bauen für verschiedene Plattformen.
Und die Möglichkeit, dass man eine Webseite so umfangreich tunet,
dass sie sich anfühlt wie eine Electron-App?
Habe ich noch nicht gesehen.
Anfühlt wie eine Electron-App?
Eine native App, meinst du?
Nein, nein, nein.
Ich habe jetzt kein Problem mit dem Browser-Tab.
Was ich bei einer Electron-App
im Prinzip bekomme,
ist ja auch den Fakt,
dass die Daten alle schon installiert wurden.
Mit der App mit.
Also ich lade mir eine App rund aus.
Das ist weg zum Beispiel.
Der HTML-Control ist drin, genau.
Und es ist alles mit da.
Es sind ganzen Grafiken mit drin,
die die Anwendung anzeigen möchte.
Es ist eigentlich nur der Inhalt nicht drin,
den ich mit meinen Leuten teilen will.
Das müsste die native App machen.
Ich meine, eine Elk von App spricht ja auch
über irgendwelche JSON-Apps oder Web-Tockets
oder was auch immer mit dem Server.
Das machst du ja genau gleich wie die native App.
Genau. Und jetzt frage ich mich, könnte man nicht einfach
in einem Cache oder einem Logistore die Daten mit ablegen?
Welche Daten?
Bilder? JavaScript?
Aber das macht ja nichts anderes.
Das läuft ja trotzdem nicht performant.
Das ist trotzdem alles in Blink-Resort.
Das ist wirklich schneller, aber ich habe zumindest keine 10 Chrome-Instanzen mehr laufen,
wenn ich 10 verschiedene Select-Teams habe.
Okay, ist da was damit zu tun?
Ich verstehe nicht, wo ich den auswählen würde.
Ich verstehe den Sammler auch nicht.
Ich will keine Electron-App installieren.
Ich werde einfach meinen Browser-Sachen verwendet.
Ach so, das ist ja eh schon der Cache,
deine Bilder und Sachen.
Es gibt auch schon sehr viele Web-Anwendungen,
die du am Anfang einmal runterlädst
und dann ist ein Fleck gesetzt,
dass die Seite, wenn du es neu aufmust,
einfach mal auf den Cache geladen wird
und das ist dann ein Skript,
was dann über eine REST-Schnittstelle
oder über Web-Squads mit dem Server spricht
und nur noch Datenaustausch.
Das gibt es ja schon lange.
Also das ist eigentlich nur noch der strengere Punkt, der lokale Zugriff.
Wenn man wahrscheinlich eine Electron-App haben wird, aber meinen Chrome-Brauchser nicht,
damit nicht jeder beliebige Webseite in meinen Bildern.
Die zwei Sachen, die ich an Electron-Apps halt scheiße finde,
ist zum einen, dass es unglaublich lange dauert, zum Teil zu starten.
Beziehungsweise nicht, dass es startet, sondern bis es ein Fenster geladen hat und mir Content anzeigt.
Und die Tatsache, dass die Dinger, wenn sie laufen, bis zu ein paar Gigabyte RAM fressen.
Meine CPU am Laufen hat wie sonst was.
Chromium und Chrome haben ja den netten Touch.
dass die generell gerne mal meine GPU mit einschalten,
was absolut unnötig ist, und auch im Laufen halten,
weil mein MacBook hat eine dedizierte zusätzliche GPU hat
und das brennt mein Akku halt absolut
nieder, also so richtig.
Obwohl ja viele
Browser extra auf
GPU-Rendering setzen,
um
sparsamer auf der, um Akku sparsamer zu sein.
Wenn du es brauchst, aber Chrome zum Beispiel,
wenn du Chrome startest, die GPU, ich hätte
eine schöne Schule, das hat ein System-Notification
an, oder der Menu war auf dem Mac,
sobald die GPU läuft
und wenn du Chrome startest,
bang, GPU an und bleibt halt auch an
für immer, dass du Chrome wieder schließt.
Was ist das?
Chrome muss das halt einfach gut aus.
Ich müsste das tun, dann wieder installieren.
Ich bin mittlerweile froh, wenn ich
so eine 3-Stunden-Zufahrt überlebe
mit laufendem Akku.
Probierst du mal ohne Chrome.
Mit Safari immer testweise.
Ja, ich bin momentan auch wieder in der Transition
von Chrome weg zu Safari hin.
Ich habe letztens mal
in die andere Richtung gewechselt.
Ich könnte ewig treu bleiben.
Ich habe letztens mal in die andere Richtung
gewechselt. Das lag vor allem daran, dass
Chrome mit gewissen Websockets
und HTTP2-Verbindungen wesentlich besser
hingehen konnte als Safari
zu dem Zeitpunkt.
Das lag unter anderem auch an
SSL-Zertifikaten. Das Problem habe ich
mittlerweile beheben können auf der anderen Seite.
Deswegen kann ich jetzt wieder Safari verwenden.
Mein Akku hält ja trotzdem nicht unbedingt
viel länger, aber immerhin
so eine Zufahrt von drei Stunden jetzt wieder
am Ende einen schwarzen
Bildschirm zu schauen. Es gibt aber
tatsächlich immer noch Leute, die neue UI-Libraries
entwickeln. Also hier von
Dino abgesehen, das ist ja
eine GTK-Anwendung, die in Vala
geschrieben ist. Viele von den Gnome-Leuten setzen jetzt
teilweise auf Rust. Das gibt es eigentlich so für UI-Bibliotheken.
Und es gibt zum Beispiel jetzt relativ
neu Realm.
Oh, beschissener Name.
Die haben aber die coole URL
realm.
R-E-L-M.
ML. Warum?
Einfach bloß, weil
das sich dann wiederholt.
Aber das ist voll die Collision mit realm.
R-E-A-L-M.io.
Ein super tolles Projekt.
Egal.
Nicht nur Eiweiß, aber das brauchen wir
ein anderes Thema für den anderen Tag.
Jetzt hast du es angefangen. Aber gut. Ja, stimmt.
Realm ist so eine Art Escalide
für S-P-E-S.
Nichts mit Escalide zu tun.
Aber es ist die hauptein gleiche Kerbe.
Also es gibt Leute,
die schon noch neue Sachen...
Was gibt es für Sachen?
Es gibt, wenn man grafische Anwendungen
bauen will, da gibt es bestimmt noch mehr, als das, was ich jetzt aufsehe.
Es gibt für
in der freien Welt gibt es
QtGTK. Auf Windows
gibt es
WPF.
Was? Ja,.NET
WPF. Dann kannst du es
auf jeder Plattform, egal ob du RAM
verwendest oder nicht,
in irgendeiner Form von HTML bauen, weil es alle
jetzt mittlerweile quasi... Ich vergiss ja
Swing nicht.
Wie kann ich das vergessen?
Coco ist das eine,
was halt ordentlich ausschaut auf macOS.
Aber das sieht bloß für den Benutzer schön aus.
Das sieht auch für den Entwickler schön aus.
Coco geht.
Also die macOS APIs sind uralt,
die sind nicht so schön auf iOS,
das ist wunderschön.
Wunderschön ist falsch, Quatsch.
Ich habe in diesem Swift
Unwrapped Podcast gehört,
es gibt Macros,
die heißen
Function Name Shortener
oder sowas? Makros gibt es nicht
in Zwift.
Bloß weil diese ganzen NS
Objective-C
Standardbibliotheks Funktionsnamen
so Meter lang waren,
haben die schon
Shortener für Funktionsnamen?
Nein, was halt Zwift macht, ist mal hier
ein kompletter Ausreißer an andere Thematik,
weil wir ja nie über Programmiersprachen reden.
Ich glaube, wir reden statistisch gesehen in ca.
100% aller unserer Folgen über
Programmiersprachen. Ich meine, wir haben diese Folge noch nicht einmal
über Programmiersprachen geredet. Das stimmt eigentlich.
wir haben tatsächlich vorhin was angesprochen.
Egal.
Objective-C hat halt endlos lange
Funktionsnamen einfach so als
gängige Praxis. Zum einen, weil
wir in der
Apple-Welt Funktionsparameternamen
nach außen hin haben. Das heißt, wir haben
Funktionsparameter,
deren Namen im Aufruf
der Funktion mit benutzt werden müssen.
Und das finde ich tatsächlich ein sehr
schönes Feature. Aber so baust du dir
halt auf Huffle-Comp raus,
Satzstrukturen als Function
Calls, die teilweise halt wirklich
bildschirmbreiten füllend sind und das ist
meiner Meinung nach ein bisschen affig und
ein UI-Kit zum Beispiel
womit du deine App
oder UI-Kit ist ein Framework für
iOS, womit du UI-Crafts und machst,
das ist halt in Objective-C implementiert
und das musst du
halt in Swift, es gibt keine Reimplementation
davon, sondern du sprichst mit
deinem Swift-Code auch nur diese Objective-C-API an.
Damit die aber nicht mega hässlich ist,
gibt es solche sogenannten Overlays,
die diese API automatisch
setzen für Swift und ein bisschen
angenehmer machen, indem ich zum Beispiel unnötige Wörter
rausschmeißen und die Parameternamen
nicht zum Beispiel
in den eigentlichen Funktionsnamen mit reinpacken.
Also in Objective-C hast du zum Beispiel so ein
Init with Full Name
Initializer auf einer Personenklasse oder so
und im Swift wird das Ganze zu einem
Init und dann ist der erste Parameter
heiß nach außen mit
und intern Full Name und
rufst du somit so auf mit Init, With und dann
dein String oder was auch immer da jetzt beispielsweise reinkommt.
Also der macht einfach den hässlich langen
Objective-C-Namen zu einem angenehmeren
Swift-Namen durch solche automatischen Übersetzungen.
Das ist vermutlich das, was die angesprochen haben.
Ich bin gar nicht sicher, was du hier an meinst.
Bei Swift gibt es irgendwie Variablen,
Funktionsparameter, die nach außen und nach innen
andere Namen haben, oder?
Ja, prinzipiell schon.
Ja, gibt es. Also du kannst
natürlich...
So was wie, nach außen heißt es With und nach innen heißt es
Name.
Ja, es gibt drei Möglichkeiten. Entweder das hat nach außen
eine Funktion, wenn du einen deklarierst, ein beliebiger Spracher
und ich habe einen Parameter, dann gibst du
eigentlich immer einen Namen für die
internen Usage in der Funktion. Das ist ja in jeder Sprache
so eigentlich. In Swift
kannst du dann nach außen hin entweder auch
diesen Namen verwenden oder du sagst, nach außen hin
hat dieser Parameter keinen Namen, dann ruft man
diese Funktion auf wie in anderen Sprachen oder
nach außen hin hat dieser Parameter einen anderen Namen,
damit du da einen schöneren Aufruf
bastelst für den API-User.
Damit es sich einfach schöner liest
und schöner aufruft.
Diese drei Möglichkeiten hast du in Swift.
Gibt es eigentlich bei Swift-Formatierern auch
Einschränkungen, dass deine Zeilen
höchstens 80 Zeichen lang sein dürfen?
SwiftLint, der eine
große tolle Linter für Swift, übrigens
von Realm, von den Realm-Leuten,
der
hat per Standard, ich glaube,
irgendein Limit drin, aber das schalte ich immer aus,
weil in der Apple-Welt
rennst du halt dank dieser Funktion
namen ständig dagegen. Du kannst natürlich
anfangen, die umzubrechen. In Object-D-C
war das auch ein bisschen schön, weil da kannst du an den Parameternamen
immer umbrechen und es hat Xcode
Default, GoTo, IDE,
auch schön sauber gemacht.
In Zwift bietet sich das nicht immer an,
manchmal, aber
Zeichen Accounts
pro Zeile finde ich nicht das eine,
was mir in Linter zumindest in Zwift anmeckern muss.
Das mache ich persönlich nicht.
Ich muss aber auch sagen, ich bin nicht so ganz
einverstanden mit
vielen Code-Formatierern,
Auto-Formatierern, gerade auch
sowas wie Clang-Format oder Rust-FMT
oder Co-FMT, die machen teilweise Sachen,
die den Code zwar auf
Zeilenlänge optimieren, oder
bei
Python, wie hieß es,
Flake? War das Flake, diese Autofilmaterie?
Das gibt es.
Die Guidelines, genau.
Und das führt teilweise
zu, das ist zwar dann
schmühlen einheitlich und man streitet sich nicht mehr
darüber, wie der Code vor Ort ist.
Ich streite mich immer mit GoFund.
Aber es trägt absolut nicht zur Lesbarkeit bei.
Ich finde, ein Befehl, ein Funktionsaufruf,
eine Initialisierung gehört auf eine Zeile
nicht auf drei. Ja, aber das ist halt deine
Meinung, Bro.
Well, that's just
your opinion, man. Ja, aber die Tatsache, dass
das zusammengestaucht wird und aufgebrochen
wird auf drei Zeilen, kommt irgendwie davon,
hängt auch damit zusammen, dass es irgendwie dieses
peckige 80 Zeichen damit gab.
Und das ist irgendwie aus Zeiten, kennt ihr noch,
Screenshots von einem alten
Eclipse, wo du irgendwie links ein Panel,
rechts ein Panel, unten ein Panel hast, oben hast du drei
Menüleisten und in der Mitte hast du noch so gefühlt
5x5 cm für deinen Code gehabt.
Da ist das sinnvoll.
Oder auch noch auf Displays, wo du so geringe Auflösung hast,
dass du wirklich maximal 80 Zeichen hinkriegst auf deinem Bildschirm.
Also viele Leute haben ja heute noch drei Editoren nebeneinander auf den drei Wim-Tabs
und plötzlich brauchst du halt solche Limits.
Sonst musst du halt ständig irgendwo scrollen.
Gerade in Editoren, wo das Scrollen ein bisschen spannender ist wie in Wim.
Ja, aber gerade wenn du in den Code-Muss überfliegst,
dann erreichen sie auch häufig die ersten 70% der Zeile.
Selbst wenn es wirklich wahr dazu kommt,
dass du den Code nicht vollständig irgendwo dargestellt bekommst,
es ist trotzdem irgendwie, was ich halt
bei Python gesehen habe, ist, du hast
irgendwie einen Funktionsaufruf mit Named Parameters,
was ja den Aufruf auch
sehr lang macht. Und was passiert?
Es muss alles in einer Zeile sein. Ja,
meinetwegen. Und dann hast du da fünf
Parameter, sechs Parameter und der letzte ist
auf der nächsten Zeile. Das ist halt semantisch
total bescheuert. Also ich habe dann angefangen,
irgendwie wirklich jeden dieser Parameter
auf eine eigene Zeile zu machen. Dann hast du halt
deinen Funktionskopf oder deinen Aufruf
vielleicht tatsächlich auch fünf Zeilen lang.
Aber da hast du es zumindest
vertikal ausgerichtet.
Eins von den beiden, entweder alles eine Zeile oder jeder Parameter
eine neue Zeile. Ja, aber es muss einheitlich sein.
Es kann nicht sein, dass du irgendwie, gerade auch
deswegen finde ich
Programmiersprachen, wo die Typen
hinter den Variablen Namen stehen,
wesentlich schöner zu lesen,
wenn du zum Beispiel
bei C++
deine Klassiken schreibst
und dann hast du da
zehn Member, was eigentlich auch schon schlecht das Deal ist,
die untereinander stehen.
Und dann hast du davor den Typen
und die Typen sind halt mal
Void, mal Int,
mal
krasser, langer, anderer
Klassenname, Typname.
Und dann fährst du da runter mit den Augen
und möchtest die Member lesen und dann springst du immer hin und her.
Weil die Typen, die davor stehen,
irgendwie dafür sorgen, dass das, was du eigentlich lesen möchtest,
der Name
des Members
irgendwie immer an einer anderen Stelle anfängt.
Da kannst du es nicht eben überfliegen.
Das stimmt.
da gibt es da Autoformatierer für
ich habe da mal so ein bisschen Liebe reingesteckt
und es dann schön zentriert dargestellt
dass es eine Seite gab, wo ein Leerzeichen war
eine Spalte
oder wo ein Leerzeichen war und auf der rechten Seite
fing dann immer an der gleichen Stelle der Name an
und links dann immer so ein bisschen versetzt
es gibt halt auch recht flexibel
eigentlich müsste es auch
es gibt auch recht flexible
Autoformatter, die halt nicht so
wie zum Beispiel Go-Format, was sie seine Regeln hatten
absolut nicht abweichen, egal was du machst
und wenn du bei den Codeformaten
issue openst, könnte man diese eine Regel
vielleicht ein bisschen schwammiger implementieren,
also wenn es nicht schwammiger ist oder irgendwas,
dann wird das issue sofort geclosed
und du wirst beleidigt quasi.
Ich finde absolut ekelhaft, wie ich das mache.
Du benutzt es etwa auch noch Syntax-Highlighting.
Du bist ja Kindergarten.
Aber es gibt flexible Codeformater,
die so ein bisschen versuchen,
deinen Style zu verstehen.
Wenn du keinen Umhoch hast im Funktionsraffung,
dann wird auch nicht umgebrochen.
Aber wenn du einen Umhoch hast,
dann brichtest du alles um
und indentiert das auch noch sauber.
Ich habe mal bei einem Projekt, an dem ich gearbeitet habe,
gefragt, darf ich dann einfach mal
die Formatierung ein bisschen lesbarer machen?
Nee, das zerstört ja die
Git-Blame-History.
Die ist ja wichtig.
Tatsächlich.
Ich bin Montag von einem angeschrieben
worden, der, du hast doch an dem und dem
mitgemacht, da habe ich jetzt gerade ein bisschen Probleme.
Ich so, da habe ich vielleicht irgendwie
drei Zeilen dran geschrieben.
Und der hat dann auf Git-Blame, der tatsächlich meine Zeile
gefunden hat. Ja, wenn du deine Git-Blame-Histin
so wichtig ist, dass du deinen Code nicht mehr anfassen kannst,
Ja, das ist feuchterlich, aber das führt natürlich
zum Beispiel deine
abgeschmetterte Nachfrage da.
Wenn du jetzt natürlich einen Codeformatter hast
oder einen Codeformatter und den einmal irgendwo
benutzt, dann hast du den als Build-Step ja meistens
drin. Das heißt, dass du den irgendwie
draufschmeißt und dann
bevor du deinen Commit machst oder bevor du baust, wird der
Code nochmal formatiert.
Wenn du jetzt die Regeln deines Formatters
änderst und den irgendwo aktualisierst,
dann macht der plötzlich Änderungen, mit denen du nicht rechnest
und dann hast du in deiner Git-History
hast du dann plötzlich einfach von deinem Codeformatter
auch welche Changes drin, die überhaupt nichts mit dem zu tun haben,
was du in dem Commit gemacht hast. Das ist fair. Der erste,
der das irgendwo, wo man dann updatet, ändert plötzlich
im ganzen Repo Dinge.
Okay, das ist ein Argument, das sehe ich an.
Also man musste dann explizit wahrscheinlich irgendwo,
wahrscheinlich kann man auch bei GitBlame sagen,
überspringen mal alle
Commits, die mit
JOR, GoFormata,
GIP-Prefix. Wenn alle dieses Schema benutzen,
zufällig.
Da gibt es auch Sachen, es gibt
von den Angular-Leuten,
Regeln für Commit-Messages,
Gerade wenn du so größere Git-Repos hast,
die mehrere Untermodule beinhalten.
Und die fangen immer an mit einem Verb.
So etwas wie fix.
Nicht ein Verb, aber ein Typ von einem Kommit.
Also fix, chore, performance, test, doc.
Und dann kommt in Klammer das Modul,
auf das es sich bezieht.
Dann deine Nachricht.
Dann die klassische Nährzeile, ein bisschen Text.
Und dann gibt es sogar noch ein Futter.
Und in dem Futter kannst du dann anfangen,
breaking changes of the list.
Oder fixes this issue.
Das ist eigentlich ein schönes
System. Und was ist jetzt
Git Emoji? Git Emoji ist quasi genau
das, wo es den Typen ersetzt durch eine Reihe
von totalisierten Emojis.
Zum Beispiel Heavy Plus sein
ist Adding a Dependency oder
diese Raupe ist Fixing a Bug und
Rocket ist Deploy Stuff und
das Log hier ist Fixing Security
Issues. Der Penguin Fixing
Something on Linux.
Das muss ich mal in unserer Slack-Post noch machen.
Arrow Down, Downgrading Dependencies.
Okay.
Whale, work about Docker.
Was ist das? Alien?
Updating code due to external API
changes. Das ist ein Alien.
Der
Palapu is writing bad code
that needs to be improved.
Bento?
Bebeers, writing code drunkenly.
Oh, das ist schön.
Ich weiß auch nicht,
das ist ja genau das, was du gerade sagst. Ich versuche mich in manchen
Projekten auch tatsächlich daran zu halten.
Das mit dem Typen kriege ich nie ganz hin, aber zumindest
Überschrift sowieso immer,
Beschreibungstext nach einer Leerzeile, ja.
Und Typ ist immer,
der erste Teil ist immer auf 50 Zeichen limitiert,
Beschreibungstext auf 72 Zeichen.
Und am Ende packe ich meistens noch C,
Issue-Nummer, so und so.
Da gibt es ja bestimmtes Wim-Highlighting für,
dass Wim direkt geheiltet,
wie du deine Mitmessages richtig machst.
Ich habe bei Wim-Highlighting glaube ich nur drin,
dass der die 50 Zeichen dann,
ab 50 Zeichen das anders...
Ja, die zweite Zeile macht er rot.
Das ist aber nicht drin, aber ich habe die GIT-Kommisse mitmessage.
Das ist eine Standardanschaung von Wim.
Okay, habe ich das falsch gefühlt gehört?
Ich habe auf jeden Fall eine Commit Message Template
mit drin, die
witzigen Kram macht und mir die ganzen
Emojis damit nochmal
Anleitung runterschmeißt, damit ich das schnell finde.
Steiger muss sich jetzt natürlich
den Stack holen, der am meisten knistert.
Oder doppelt eingepackt ist.
Ich habe schon verkackt mit meinem Kinderregel.
Also wenn ihr so komisches Rauschen hört, das sind keine Artefakte von schlechter
Kodierung, das ist einfach, wie essen die die ganze Zeit
das nächste Mal. Wir nehmen diese Folge im ASCII auf.
Wir sind übrigens wieder gesponsert von Collabata.
Yay, Collabata!
Also Kolomate,
die uns absolut nichts schenkt,
sondern die wir ja mit dem ASCII für Teuergeld
abkaufen.
Aber Kolomate hat getwittert,
die Tatsache, dass ihr diesen Podcast nicht auf anderthalbfacher
Geschwindigkeit hören müsst, liegt daran, dass wir ganz viel
Kolomate trinken.
Gehen wir aber zurück zu
Elektronen.
Wo wir eigentlich herkommen, bevor wir den großen Umschäuf gemacht haben.
Ja, kommt halt vor.
Also eigentlich nur, um das kurz abzuschließen,
ich habe das damals noch aufgeschnappt, weil ich das
in einem Blogpost gelesen habe. Dann habe ich meinen
Activity Monitor gestoppt,
festgestellt, ja, das ist ganz schlimm
gerade bei mir auch auf dem System.
Die Performance ist fast Slack.
Slack, Spotify
und ich hatte noch was anderes aufgeschrieben.
Gibt es noch so andere bekannte
Elektronen? Vivaldi ist ein Browser, der
in Elektronen geschrieben ist.
Vivaldi selber? Vivaldi ist ein Elektronen.
So, hey,
put in Browser,
into your browser.
I hope you like Browser.
oder Nylis, das hatten wir ja vorher mal angesprochen,
diesen komischen Creepy Mail-Client,
der genauso wie die Outlook-iOS-App
deine
auch Information, zumindest war das so,
auf deren Server schmeißt, die machen,
der Server macht die Verbindung zu deinem IMAP
und du sprichst nur noch mit deren Server,
um deine E-Mails unterzuladen.
Ja, gruselig.
Aber haben es nicht einige von den
iOS-Mährenbindungen auch gemacht?
Im Outlook hat er so gemacht.
Da gab es einen riesen Flame-More und dann haben sie
das Gummi erinnert und bei dem spricht
wie App.imap. Das ist aber schön.
Also ich habe das, wie gesagt, damals
noch gelesen. Back to Electron.
Back to Electron, dass es extrem
viel Ressourcen verbraucht, dass man
ich weiß nicht, man hat ja wahrscheinlich
auch noch die ganzen Bugs und alles mit.
Vielleicht könnt ihr das ja mal in die Richtung abändern,
dass man sagt, ich nutze einfach das installierte
Chrome oder das Chrome.
Du hast auch Probleme, dass
du benutzt ja Schnittstellen, die sich potenziell ändern.
Auf der nativen Seite
auf der Air-Kotretien-Seite.
Oder man strengt sich halt an
und baut es halt nativ.
Weil auch zum Beispiel den Vorschlag,
den ich da noch hatte,
ich habe für Overcast zum Beispiel,
das habe ich mir in eine Fluid-App gepackt.
Und Fluid war so eine kleine Mac-App,
mit der du einfach eine Webseite
rappen konntest,
damit es in einem Web-Kit-View
zu einer Mac-App wurde.
Es ist im Prinzip ein Safari.
Und es macht genau das gleiche.
So ein Konzert-Safari, genau.
Ja, es ist im Prinzip klasse.
an der Lektron.
Elektron ist halt lokale.
Und ohne lokale Zukunftsrechte.
Also im Prinzip kann ich da eine Webseite
darstellen. Das fährt zum Beispiel auch bei mir,
wenn ich irgendwie im Bitbucket,
habe ich einen Auftritt fix zusammengeklickt,
die Webseite einfach
browsen möchte, aber es macht es nicht
besser. Es ist eigentlich nur,
mach man da vor. Naja, ich habe jetzt angefangen,
die Slack-Teams, in denen ich tatsächlich aktiv bin,
einfach nur als Safari-Tab offen zu halten.
Und das läuft bedeutend besser, weil
Safari, die im Hintergrund auch wegkillt.
Wenn ich so lange nicht drauf war, wenn ich dann drauf
gehe, dann steht da halt für drei Sekunden Reconnecting
und dann macht er die Verbindung wieder auf, aber das
ressourcenmäßig macht das einen riesigen
Unterschied. Also das ist quasi der Quick-Fix,
pack deine Sachen, wenn es geht,
einfach an den eigenen Tab mit Safari.
Das geht halt nur für die Elektron-Apps, die halt
Webseiten spiegeln. Es gibt halt diverse Elektron-Apps,
Spotify gibt es auch eine Webseite,
aber Atom zum Beispiel, das gibt es halt nur als
die Elektron-App.
Richtig, richtig.
Wir sollten nur von Sachen reden, die auch wirklich
als lokale Anwendungen verwendbar sind.
Im Endeffekt könntest du
jede Anwendung in deinen Browser schieben.
Dann hast du nicht mehr deine Taskleiste unten,
sondern da hast du deine Browserzeile oben.
Das nervt auch.
Das ist ja nicht das Gleiche.
Also der Electron-App ist ja keine Webseite.
Das ist ja wirklich was anderes.
Ich muss aber tatsächlich sagen,
ich habe es auch mal selber verglichen,
Visual Studio Code
ist ein wunderschöner Editor,
basiert auf Electron
und ist ein ganzes Stück flutter als Atom.
Ja, aber trotzdem zehnmal langsamer heißt es, bleiben.
Ja.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Wobei ich wieder an dem Punkt war,
wenn du zum Beispiel eine IDE aufmachst,
Visual Studio oder
Xcode, dann guckst du auch noch dazu,
bis es aufgeht. Gut, das ist doch viel mehr zu machen.
Es ist halt kein Wim.
Visual Studio Code ist jetzt irgendwo
so ein Zwischending zwischen IDE und Editor.
Es ist schon mehr als nur ein Editor.
Was halt Electron Apps auch wunderschön nicht können im Vergleich
zu Native Editoren ist, um einen großen Dateien
und da sterben sie einfach komplett dran.
VSCode macht das immer clever. Atom stirbt einfach dran.
VSCode sagt, ey, die Datei ist zu groß,
die öffne ich die mal nicht.
Die haben da immer einen schönen Check, bevor wir
in der Datei drin, wie groß die
Teufendatei eigentlich ist.
Eigentlich kannst du für solche Sachen,
ich warte nur darauf, dass man mal
einen Terminal-Emulator baut.
Gibt es HyperJS? Ist ein Electronic Terminal?
Nein, nicht ein Electronic.
Achso, okay. Das ist ja genau falsch rum.
Das ist genau falsch rum.
Ich dachte, was wolltest du?
Ich möchte quasi einen Terminal-Emulator
als Toolkit für
Anwendungen, die Terminal-basiert sind.
Dass du sagen kannst, ich nehme jetzt sowas wie Vim
und dem gebe ich aber noch mehr Möglichkeiten.
Indem ich zum Beispiel sage, du kannst jetzt
an bestimmten Stellen kannst du auch Grafiken malen.
Hast du so eine Art GVim?
Genau. Das ist zum Beispiel
GVim oder MacVim. Das sind ja
eigentlich auch bloß aufgebohrte Terminal-Emulatoren,
wo dann ein Vim drin läuft, mit denen die dann sprechen.
Das ist an und für sich kacke, weil das
jedes Mal, wenn du was aktualisierst,
wenn du so eine ganze Zeile
oder so eine ganze
Textseite quasi neu gebaut.
Das ist ein Rendering in Wim eigentlich langsam.
Das kannst du jetzt nur bekämpfen,
indem du so einen Terminal-Emulator nimmst,
wie Alacrity.
Das ist so
der erste Terminal-Emulator, der
den Terminal-Inhalt komplett auf der GPU rendert.
Und der ist nicht schnell.
Der ist absolut wahnsinnig schnell.
Also Hendrik hat mir den mal
kürzlich gezeigt und es ist
unglaublich.
Du kannst mal in einem normalen
Item CutDevRandom machen
und schauen, was passiert.
Und dann machst du es in der Lackertie an,
dann siehst du nur noch weißes Rausch.
Das war glaube ich ein GitHub-Sahle-Woche
in unserer Unruhe, kann das sein?
Wir müssen echt aufpassen,
dass wir uns nicht wiederholen.
Wir müssten irgendwie so eine Themenliste führen
und dann müssten wir uns das hinhängen und schauen,
oh Gott, haben wir darüber schon gesprochen,
oder wie schiffen wir das jetzt?
Aber zum Beispiel, ich würde das gerne haben,
dass jemand Wim nimmt und dem noch sagt,
okay, pass auf, ich hebe das jetzt nicht in den Terminal Emulator,
sondern in diesen Terminal Emulator Plus Plus
und da kann man auch
Zum Beispiel dieses Git-Gatter an der Seite
oder diese
Blogs für
Breakpoints,
diese kleinen
Knubbel an der Seite.
So was.
Was wir haben wollen, ist
Aliquity plus Encurses plus
Maus-Support als Framework.
Ja, eigentlich
möchtest du sowas doch nicht machen.
Ich musste gerade an der Stelle kurz an
Nix denken. Das ist ein uralter
Textbrowser.
Genau, und als im Linux-Körner irgendwie an den Frame-Backer-Sachen umgebaut wurde,
damit die Grafik auf der Konsole, also das war einfach irgendwie mal ein bisschen mehr als 80-mal 20 Zeichen,
auch mal Textzeile sehen konnte, wurde dort auch Grafik-Support in Luxemite irgendwie eingebaut.
Wir bräuchten einen ganz guten Hack und die hatten tatsächlich die Grafiken eingeblendet im Textbrowser.
Das Problem war nur, die Standard-Hintergrundfarbe auf der Konsole ist schwarz und in dem Browser ist sie weiß.
Wenn du deine Grafik hattest, dann war die häufig
so ein weißer Block in einem schwarzen
Nichts. Das ist eigentlich
super schön. Bei Twitter gibt es auch so ein paar
Fotos, die ich aussetze.
Das sind halbtransparente GIFs,
die, wenn du dir das
in der kleinen Ansicht anguckst, haben den weißen
Hintergrund. Und wenn du das Bild dann groß machst,
wenn die Rangesunke kriegen, die plötzlich einen schwarzen
hinterkommt, dann siehst du plötzlich, dass diese Person
nicht vor einer weißen Wand steht, sondern vor so einem Sternenhimmel.
Weil es nämlich eigentlich ein transparenter
Hintergrund war, wenn du so ein paar Punkte
weiß war. Das hast du mit dem weißen Hintergrund nicht gesehen.
und plötzlich ist der Hintergrund schwarz
und er leuchtet eine Stern.
Witzig.
Total cool.
Ja.
Aber dann schließen wir Elektron
und lassen wir das mal ab.
Alternativen gibt es nicht wirklich.
Es gibt Positron.
Das ist das Gleiche auf Gekko-Basis.
Ah, cool.
Guter Name, sehr guter Name.
Ist das auch komplett Cross-Plattform?
Nein, es ist genauso Cross-Plattform
wie Firefox wahrscheinlich.
Warum nicht auf Servobasis?
Darauf warte ich eigentlich als nächstes.
Ich würde ja an der Stelle vielleicht, weil du gerade
den Stammhüller erwähnt hast, mal was komplett
Interdisziplinäres bringen.
Und nur kurz darauf hinweisen, dass er kürzlich
dein Liebhuton im Fernflas zu beobachten hat.
Oh shit.
Das ist nicht immer?
Nein, also der ist eigentlich immer sehr, sehr, sehr weit weg.
Irgendwie so ein Milliarderkilometer.
Aber du kannst mir das, die Monde dahinter
auf sich.
Ja, kann ich mir noch was machen.
Mit dem Fernrohr, aber mit einem Fernrohr.
Mit einem Fernrohr, genau.
Du meinst jetzt mit einem normalen Feldstecher.
Ich meine mit einem normalen Feldstecher.
ich habe das letztens genießen können
und habe ich irgendwie gelesen
ja, Jogetra ist gerade ganz ganz ganz nah
guckt mal links vom Mond
das war vor zwei Wochen
da war Vollmond
und tatsächlich, den konnte man sehen als gelben Punkt
zum Fernklaas und maximale Vergrößerung
hat man eine Weile gesucht
hat man ihn dann gefunden
ich habe tatsächlich drei der galilienischen Monde
sehen können
und ich hoffe, dass ein paar Hörer das vielleicht auch gemacht haben
und sich darüber freut haben
dass der Jupiter nicht die normale
Milliarde Kilometer weit weg ist,
sondern nur ein paar hundert Millionen.
Ja, so doll schwankt
der Unterschied jetzt seitdem auch nicht.
Der ist seitdem du das geordnet hast,
jetzt auch nicht so viel weiter weg.
Der braucht glaube ich 120 Jahre
für eine Erdbeleitung.
Nicht so lange, aber länger als wir, klar.
Wir sind länger als wir.
22 Jahre.
Ich glaube, was da meistens signifikant ist,
ist, dass der an der Stelle am Himmel steht,
gut siehst und nicht, also sich kurz hinter dem Horizont
oder über dem Horizont. Das kann sein.
Es gibt bei irgendeinem
D-Radio, die Deutschlandfunk
Podcast, den ich mal eine Zeit lang gehört
habe. Deutschlandfunk
Forschung und Wissen,
ne, Forschung aktuell.
Da gab es Computer und Kommunikation.
Sehr kurz dieser Podcast.
Und da kam zum Schluss immer
so eine Astronomie
Sektion, wo sie dir erzählt haben,
was du jetzt gerade, weil du den Podcast vor einer Woche
aufgezeichnet bekommen hast und jetzt erst hörst,
was du jetzt gerade schon wieder am Sternenhöl verpasst hast.
Oh!
Bei den Podcasten. Also da kommt dann immer,
morgen können sie kurz nach
Sonnenuntergang auf der Westseite
die Venus
wunderschön leuchten sehen, aber nur noch
bis zum kommenden Sonntag,
den 24. April,
und du guckst ja auf den Kalender
und denkst dir so, fuck, das war vorgestern.
oder ist es schnell vorbei.
Aber aktuelle Nachrichten
funktionieren an Podcasts nicht.
Ja, das stimmt. Wir sind ja auch immer sehr
zeitnah veröffentlicht, deshalb sprechen wir von
aktuellen Themen.
Wir können hier über Themen reden, die wir gerade auf
Hacker News gelesen haben, die bis zu dem Zeitpunkt der
Veröffentlichung die Leute schon wieder vergessen haben.
Apropos Hacker News.
Das ist so ein geiles Projekt,
heute erst, leider mit dem Tag verzögerung.
Juicero heißt das.
Das ist ein Startup aus
wahrscheinlich Ostküste USA,
die haben sowas Geiles
ins Leben gerufen, die haben eine Saftpresse.
Eine 600 Dollar,
mittlerweile 400 Dollar
Saftpresse, die
wie du bei so einer Kaffeepadmaschine
dir so
Saftbeutel kaufst, die hängst
du in diese Saftpresse rein, stellst eine Tasse
drunter und dann drückt dir diese
Saftbeutel aus mit 4 Tonnen
Zucker. Und
jemand hat rausgefunden, dass
wenn du diesen Saftbeutel einfach mit der Hand
ausdrückst, du dir diese 400
Dollar fucking Saftpresse
sparen kannst, weil es
den Zell perfekter ist.
Und diese Kraft, die du überhaupt nicht brauchst, weil der Saft einfach
in diesem Saftbeutel drin ist, die wollen eh bloß Geld mit dem
Saftbeutel machen.
Das ist quasi so eine Espresso-Maschine,
bloß, dass die halt nicht Espresso-Pads
mit heißem Wasser durchspült, sondern einfach
Saft aus so einem Saftbeutel.
Du hängst einen Saftbeutel rein.
Und sie sieht schick aus.
Und ich habe das heute früh auch gelesen.
Und das ist extremely wasteful.
Das Witzige ist natürlich, dass die Saftpresse
eine aktive Internetverbindung braucht, um so gut funktionieren.
Die haben natürlich eine App
und die Features, die die Saftpresse natürlich hat,
die in diesem 400 Dollar
drinstecken, dass die das
über den Code, der auf deinem
DM-Geschützten
Saftpaket drauf ist, feststellt, ob das schon
abgelaufen ist und die Saftpresse weigert sich,
abgelaufene Pakete auszudrücken.
Aber da wir hier von Nachmitteln reden, muss der
Ablaufdatum ja eh drauf gedruckt werden.
Du kannst das Mensch genauso lesen.
Ich dachte, jetzt kommt sowas wie
Qualify-Yourself-Features,
dass du dir das auf deine Apple Watch schickst.
Wie viel wird da die 10-Leute schon?
Das könnte natürlich funktionieren, aber ist es das
400 Dollar wert? Das Krasse ist, die Firma
hat 120 Millionen
Dollar von Googles Venture
Capitalist teilbekommen.
What the actual fact.
Diverse Investoren haben jetzt,
nachdem dieses Video von wegen, dieses Hack-Video
von wegen, ich drücke den Beutel einfach mit der Hand aus,
veröffentlicht wurde, haben gesagt,
ich wusste gar nicht, dass man das auch ohne die Presse
ausdrücken kann.
Wie lieben die Leute denn rein?
Ich möchte gerade fast unterstellen,
wenn ich mir diese Bilder hier angucke,
die haben nie einen Prototypen gebaut.
Das ist ja alles irgendwie mit Blender gerendert.
Die haben ein paar Fotos zusammengeklickt,
um dieses Venture-Kapital
abzustauben.
Und das ist halt
ein großer Scam, oder?
Ich glaube, die Leute, die diese
Sachpresse hier bauen, die lachen sich
übelst ins Fäuste. Das Geile ist,
Der CEO ist so ein Fisch,
der hat so ein Statement jetzt veröffentlicht, wo er versucht,
das zurecht zu fertigen, aber der
bezeichnet sich selbst als auch den
Steve Jobs of Juice.
Wie kaum musst du damit sagen?
Das sieht ein bisschen aus wie dieser komische Apple Cube.
Next Cube?
Nee, achso, du meinst Mac Pro.
Wie hieß das Ding? Das haben sie bei
den Simpsons verarscht.
Ich frage mich, was es für dich tun kann.
Ich frage mich, was du für bist.
Ich habe heute früh
diese Nachricht gelesen und ich habe im ersten Moment
tatsächlich gedacht, es ist eine richtige Saftpresse,
wo man so richtig Orangen oben reinlegt.
Das hätte ich mir fast gedacht, so eine Sension.
Aber in Beutel,
du kaufst für 5 bis 8 Dollar
einen Beutelsaft.
Ja, für 5 bis 8 Dollar
kaufe ich mir zwei Säcke Orangen
und dann kriege ich mir frühe
15 Orangensafte aus.
Also ich warte darauf, dass es von der Ethical Company
diese Saftbeutel aus dem
biologisch abbaubaren Stoff gibt.
Was die Firma jetzt vermachen muss,
das hat einer in den heilen Kommentaren vorgeschlagen,
ist erstmal die Beutel widerstandsfähiger zu machen,
sodass du die nicht mit der Hand ausdrücken kannst.
Dann am besten noch zwei Wandig,
sodass du eine ekelhaft schmeckende Flüssigkeit dazwischen packen kannst,
falls einer versucht, die aufzuschneiden.
Also das ist hier absolut gut.
Ach genau, dann musst du aber vorher,
du musst deine Maschine auch so ein proprietäres Lock aufmachen,
damit du den Saft nur an der Stelle durchbekommst,
wo du nicht diese vergeltende Flüssigkeit in dem geschütztes Ventil hast.
Und dann sind die Beutel...
Das ist so kaputt.
Dann musst du es wirklich richtig Apple-mäßig machen.
Die nächste Generation ist nur noch mit einer neuen Form
Beutelkompatibel.
Kannst du dich mal einhängen.
Man verkaufst nur noch Generation 2 Beutel
und dann müssen die Leute sich für 400 neue
eine neue Maschine kaufen, um den Saft daraus zu pressen.
Das ist so eine dumme...
Wenn ich mir diese Verpacken allein anschaue,
wie aufwendig das gemacht habe.
Das ist so viel Müll.
Das ist unglaublich.
Ja, aber naja, gut,
eine Safttüte ist jetzt nicht
mehr als so ein Tetapack.
Der Saftpresse hat nichts davon.
Warum verkaufe ich mir für 400 Dollar diesen Scheiß,
wo ich immer Plastiktüten wegwerfe,
anstatt ein Saftpresse, wo ich einfach mein Obst so oben reinplacke.
Ich sage nur, so eine Tüte
ist weniger Müll-zu-Inhalt-Ratio
als ein Tetrapack.
Aber es ist definitiv mehr Müll
als die natürliche Verpackung der Frucht.
Die Ormschale zum Beispiel.
Du kannst ja in den USA auch Bananen kaufen,
die wurden bereits ausgepackt und in Plastik neu verpackt.
Ja.
Geschälte.
Genau, geschälte Bananen in Plastik.
es ist so widerlich
und so viel Umwelchverschmutzung
was the fuck
es werden nicht braun
die werden aber auch in ihrer Schale nicht braun
doch die Schale braun
die wird auch schlecht in der Plastikverpackung
das ist eigentlich
eigentlich ist das absolut falsch
now available in 17 states
ich mach dieses
Demo-Video läuft hier gerade
ich muss gleich eine lange Kondermate holen
vor allem das Zirch sieht so herrlich cool aus
Ich habe mir neulich ein Getränk bei...
Das habe ich echt überlegt,
durch das dem ASCII-Vorschlag bei Nordsee gekauft.
Das heißt Helga.
Da habe ich schon was von gemacht.
Das sieht genauso grün aus wie das hier.
Das ist quasi, wenn du die Zutaten durchdichst,
das ist eigentlich eine Zitronenlimo.
Also es ist eine Zitronensäure drin und Zucker.
Und das ist ganz normal.
Aber es ist halt so grün wie diese Algenplörer hier.
Weil es ist Algenplörer drin.
Das ist ein Eigenblöger.
Ja, da steht ja drauf,
dass da halt eine bestimmte Alge drin ist,
die du auch so im Reformhaus
dir als Nahrungsergänzungsmittel kaufst.
Da steht auch tatsächlich Nahrungsergänzungsmittel drauf.
Da ist halt Vitamin B12 drin.
Das ist tatsächlich interessant für Leute,
die Vegetarier oder Veganer sind, weil Vitamin 12
kriegst du sonst bloß aus Fleisch oder Leber oder so.
Wie oft ich Leber esse
oder Fleisch allgemein auch weniger,
aber Leber nie.
Ich habe bei einem Praktikum
an einer App mitgearbeitet, die hieß Fit und Gesund.
Die hatte ich quantifiziert. Das war so eine der
ersten Quantify-yourself-Anwendungen, was das
leider nie aus der Tür geschafft hat.
Da hatten wir so eine Lebensmitteldatenbank und eine Sportdatenbank.
Da hast du
eingeben können,
was du gegessen hast. Dann hast du so Grafen
gekriegt mit
wie viel von meiner täglichen Ration XYZ
habe ich heute zu mir genommen.
Da konntest du dir auch aus Zutaten deine eigenen Lebensmittel
zusammenbauen. Wir haben dann mal überlegt, also Composite Pattern
konntest du dann aus Milch, Zucker,
Mehl und so weiter und so fort
die einen Knoppers zusammenbauen.
Dann konntest du halt eingeben, ich habe heute
zehn Möhren gegessen und drei Orangen
getrunken und dann hat es
drei Beutel
Juicero-Orangen-Kraft genommen und dann hat es
dir gesagt, dass du zu wenig Salz
zu dir nimmst oder sowas.
Da konntest du auch sagen, ich war heute fünf Minuten joggen,
drei Stunden Rasenmähen,
acht Jahre Fahrradfahren
und
dieser Sport- und Lebensmittel
das haben wir von irgendwelchen Instituten bekommen,
da war es sinnloses Steugs dabei.
Da war zum Beispiel für jede Aktivität,
je nach Zeit, wie viele Kalorien du dabei verbrannt hast,
kamen auch dazu,
da waren so Sachen drin wie Flugzeug ziehen.
Wie viele Kalorien
du dabei beim Flugzeug ziehen verbrannt hast.
Zumindest kam raus,
Vitamin B12 ist da und da,
da haben wir mal nachgeschlagen, wie viel brauchen wir denn
als Mensch davon und
wie lange ist es im Körper vorhanden,
bis es abgebaut wird. Im Endeffekt hast du,
wenn du einmal Leber isst, genug Vitamin B12
für ein nächstes Jahr zu dir genommen.
Aber das stößt dein Körper bestimmt wieder aus dir aus.
Das stößt dein Körper wieder aus, aber die Menge, die du da zu dir nimmst,
reicht irgendwie für...
Wenn du extrem wenig brauchst, wenn du sowas wie Leber
extrem viel drin hast.
Beindruckend.
Du könntest im Prinzip so ein bisschen Leber irgendwo implementieren.
Implementieren.
Implantieren lassen.
Wie ist das Interface?
Hast du nicht schon da einige?
Wollen wir noch irgendwas zu Elektronen sagen,
um nochmal den Bogen zurückzuschlagen?
Gibt es noch irgendwas, was man sagen könnte?
Elektron ist tot.
Leider nicht.
Vielleicht gibt es ja irgendwas besseres.
Vielleicht kann man es ja irgendwas servobasiert auf und lassen.
Dann läuft es immer schneller, besser vielleicht.
Schaut euch mal die Demos an
für Rendering auf
Servo.
Die schießen, was Rendering-Speed
angeht, ziemlich alle anderen Browser
aus dem Wasser. Das freut mich.
Wie groß ist der Vorsprung da?
Also Demos, wo
Firefox und Chrome so
9 bis 15
Frames zu kriegen, macht
Zero mit 60 und
60 war, weil 60 irgendwo hart eingestellt war.
Die machen
halt alles, was Rendering angeht,
möglichst parallel,
wo es geht und lagern extrem viel
auch mit ihrem Web-Renderer, der
zunächst auch in Firefox reinwandert, auf die CPU
aus, auf die GPU aus.
Deswegen sage ich, eigentlich machen wir, die sagen halt
GPU machen wir, weil
naja, guckt ihr mal den Prozessor an, wir möchten möglichst viel
vom Prozessor nutzen, deswegen machen wir alles paratär.
Aber wenn du dir so einen modernen Prozessor anguckst, guck mal,
hier ist ein Schaltplan von dem Prozessor. Das da unten
links ist die eigentlich CPU, weil die ist
immer kleiner geworden und alles rundherum ist
so Cache und auch ganz viel halt
System on a Chip GPU, die
immer mit dabei ist und mittlerweile auf jeder
modernen CPU
mit verlötet ist. Das wäre ja Quatsch, wenn wir das nicht nutzen.
Ich habe ja auch diesen Intel-Grafik-Chips,
den du ja auch ansprechen kannst. Du musst
ja nicht meine dedizierte GPU
zum Batterie-Runterbrennen nutzen.
Und das, was es immer noch langsam gemacht hat,
ist halt Text Rendering, weil die ganzen Text Rendering
Libraries alle noch auf dem CPU
gearbeitet haben. Aber,
und Wunder auf Wunder, Leute aus dem Mozilla
Research-Umfeld haben jetzt einfach
GPU-basierte
Text Rendering Libraries gebaut.
Da gibt es, ich kann nur empfehlen,
die Videos auf
r.mozilla.org, die
gerade die Rust-Meetups,
wo sie erzählen, was sie jetzt alles cool ist,
noch mit Rust gebaut haben.
Gerade der Vortrag über diesen Fund-Renderer
auf der GPU. Das ist extrem spannend,
allein weil da unterschiedliche Verfahren
mit den Schriftarten gerendert
werden können, auseinander nimmt
und darstellt. Wenn jetzt mal den
Bogen zurück ist, gibt es ja diesen Terminal Emulator,
der auf der GPU rendert.
Im Endeffekt hat der einfach die
ganzen Glyphs, die du darstellen
kannst, einfach irgendwo mal als Bitmaps gecached
und glippelt die hin und her,
weil das Rendering von Fonts noch nicht
auf der GPU gemacht werden kann, weil der es noch nicht
machen kann. Das ist jetzt quasi auch was,
was die als nächstes einbauen, das ist Font-Rendering.
das Team mit einbauen.
Dann kannst du dann auch
stufenlos scrollen, zum Beispiel.
Oder Zoom.
Da gibt es, der hat Demos gezeigt,
wo einfach geil
stufenlos Text gesucht wird.
Das ist eigentlich was, was man nicht gewohnt wird.
Wenn ich jetzt hier auf dem Mac bei dir mal
Steuerung drücke und hoch und runter scrolle.
Das zoomt ja nur den Bildschirminkonten.
Das zoomt ja nur den Bildschirmkonten.
Wenn ich auf meinen Cursor
und auf den Texte zeige,
dass das auch ein Pix-Licht war.
aber das ist ja nicht dafür gedacht.
Man stelle dir vor,
der Text wird stufenlos einfach schärfer.
Das muss auch alles mit dem System nisten.
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Das hat er dann in so einer Demo gezeigt.
Apropos nochmal,
ich melde mich ja hier aus der Seite
der Rust Evangelism Task Force.
Strikeforce.
Ich könnte noch ein cooles Projekt nennen,
was in Rust geschrieben ist.
Nämlich,
wo stand's?
Ruby Go.
Das ist nämlich ein Go-Package-Manager,
der in Rust geschrieben ist.
Man könnte ja,
müsste man was bauen für Go,
nämlich so ein Package-Manager. Wollen bauen wir den denn?
In Rust.
Der Name hat mich so ein bisschen an Ruby erinnert,
hat aber überhaupt nichts damit zu tun.
Und der ist,
der venderte deine Dependencies,
global oder lokal,
und der rüscht momentan bloß Git-Repositories.
Wir brauchen mal noch anderes. Das ist ja alles Quatsch.
Ja, ja.
Theoretisch hätte man noch auch schon vor...
Ich kann sogar auf GitHub noch spezifizieren.
Wir brauchen schon Git neben GitHub.
Wir unterstützen nur GitHub als Remote.
Nee, nee, hier steht bloß
GitHub-Repositories, nicht GitHub.
Ich weiß, ich habe es noch ein bisschen übertrieben
überspitzt.
Im Endeffekt ist das ein sinnvolleres Format dafür.
Ich meine, du holst
hier mit GitHub deine Refs.
Du kannst Text
angeben, du kannst Versionen damit gut adressieren.
an und für sich ist das sinnvoll,
anstatt dass du dir jedes Mal Tabor oder irgendwas
unterlädst.
Ich muss machen das auch genauso.
Ich meine, du hättest auch schon vor 5 Jahren deine Go-Projekte
mit NPM packagen können.
Ja, lass mal wieder auf die Idee springen,
dass wir alles auf NPM schmeißen.
Ress los.
Zumindest Rubigo. Ich habe es mir bloß mal kurz
überflogen, weil ich habe leider keinen Use Case dafür,
weil ich nichts mit Go mache.
Aber was mich ein bisschen dran gestellt hat,
es gibt hier so ein Beispiel,
du schreibst halt deine
rubigo.json für dein Projekt und dann gibt es halt
eine rubigo.log, weil du brauchst halt Logfiles
und das Problem ist halt, das ist eine rubigo.json
das heißt, das ist nichts, was du schön per Hand
schreiben kannst, das ist halt hier so eine JSON
und JSON ist halt scheiße, wenn du Sachen per Hand schreibst, also es wäre schön
im nächsten Schritt eine rubigo.tommel
oder eine rubigo.jambel
zumindest anzubieten. Oder
hasten, dieses humanjson.
Oder eine rubigo-file.
Ganz ehrlich, ich
höre mir ja bei JSON, dass es nicht wirklich
JavaScript-Syntax ist. Also du musst,
du hast nur
Strings als Keys.
Du kannst keine Keywords als Keys haben.
Du kannst keine Kommentare reinpacken.
Du kannst auch
kein Komma zu viel.
Du kannst auch keine Trailing-Kommas haben.
Einmal für sich ist Jason.
Nein, gut, okay.
Ist halt nicht so,
ob du gerne Menschen schreibst.
Daneben liegt halt in dem gleichen Ordner
hier die cargo.tommel und die cargo.log.
Das ist halt ein Rust-Projekt.
Aber es ist ja nicht witzig, dass er es in Rust schreibt
und nicht einfach Tommel nimmt.
Das liegt direkt als Beispiel daneben, weil
in dem Projekt von seinem Paketmanager hat er
ein Beispiel, wie man so eine
Paketbeschreibung...
Er hätte im Endeffekt das
identische Format nehmen können wie Cargo Toml.
Ich finde es immer noch komisch.
Toml ist auch eine komische Sprache.
Jamel fände ich besser.
Das Problem an Jamel ist, man bräuchte...
Ja, Jamel ist syntaktisch
schöner, aber man bräuchte eigentlich
ein Subset von Jamel.
So ein Jamel 2.
Witzigerweise ist ja,
die Möglichkeiten von YAML
von 1.1 zu 1.2
sind weniger geworden.
Es gibt ja Bull und die Konstruktion,
wie wir es das letzte Mal schon bei CoffeeScript hatten,
kannst du bei YAML auch mit Yes und No
hinschreiben. Und das haben sie
von 1.1 auf 1.2
wieder rausgenommen. Das heißt, mit
YAML 1.2 kannst du nicht mehr Yes und No hinschreiben.
Das wird dann per Standard als
String interpretiert.
Bei YAML kannst du an Sachen hinten
mit Ausrufezeichen Typen hinschreiben.
Bei YAML kannst
Entitäten mit Namen versehen
und die später referenzieren, um die
reinzupasten. Das verwende ich zum Beispiel
bei dem ASCII-Invoice,
den ich gebaut habe. Da hast du oben ein Feld,
wo einfach bloß Katalog steht und da stehen dann
Entities, da steht dann Sternchen Kaffee und
Sternchen Kekse und sowas.
Und dann schreibst du unten dein Projekt, schreibst du nur noch
Produkt, Doppelpunkt
und Kaffee
oder andersrum, Sternchen Kaffee
und du referenzierst und dann wird im Prinzip
das, was du oben geschrieben hast, unten kannst du
mehrmals einfügen.
dadurch musst du die Sachen
nicht immer wieder abschreiben
es gibt auch solche komische Pipe-Syntax
dass du innerhalb von YAML
Datenstrukturen mit anderen Datenstrukturen
auffüllen kannst
also YAML ist schön
aber YAML kann zu viel
deswegen hast du YAML-Implementierungen
die die Großteil des Features gar nicht
abbilden, was die meisten Leute
nicht stört, bis es mal jemand benutzt
und dann hast du halt
Anwendungsfälle, die einfach nicht gehen
und die du da nicht portieren kannst
bei dem Parser,
bei dem ASCII-Involution, als ich den von Ruby
nach Rust portiert habe,
auch erstmal warten und
an dem Parser ein bisschen mitarbeiten,
damit diese Referenzierung
von Items damit unterstützt
wird. Vorher ist das einfach gefressen worden
vom Parser und ist einfach verschwunden.
Das ist das Problem an YAML. Es ist schön,
dass es ein lesbares,
eingestrukturiertes
Superset von
Jason ist. Du kannst das alles
auch, deine Keys, kannst auch
Strich inschreiben oder ohne.
Du kannst auch alles auf einer Zeile mit geschweiften
Klammern schreiben, aber es macht zu viel.
Tommel
ist eigentlich nur eine konsequentere
Verkürzung des Problems,
aber Tommel hat dann die Sitzag schon ja ein bisschen
zu sehr verändert. Um mal kurz auf diesen Punkt
mit diesen ganzen Sonderfällen, nenne ich
jetzt mal, zu gehen, dann müsste es eigentlich mal
so ein Set geben an Test
Jamel-Files, wo man halt alles,
was diese Standardkarte in der Version
kann und spezifiziert
testen kann gegen seine Logos.
Man sagt, hier hast du eine Jamelfile,
die benutzt dieses Feature,
hier benutzt dieses Feature und
das, was dann am Endeffekt
eingelesen wird und interpretiert wird
in der Jamelfile, muss so aussehen.
Diese Datenstruktur. Das ist dann eigentlich mal
eine relativ praktische Sache. Und das andere,
was ich zu Jamelfile gerne noch losladen will,
ich könnte jedes Mal
an die Decke gehen wegen Tabs und
Leerzeichen. Wie oft
mir irgendwas um die Ohren fliegt, weil
einfach mein Textetitor der Meinung ist,
ach, du hast doch mal kein Syntax-Halletting
gemacht, das ist kein Jammer, das ist ein Problem.
Ach, mach mal einen Tab hier hin.
Und dann speichest du es ab und dann sagt dein Programm,
ach, das ist kein Jammer.
Aber das ist ja auch mit deinem Editor.
Welche Sprache war das, die Tabs als Syntaxfehler
interpretiert?
Python, das mischt.
Also das hätte ich ja schon gerne.
Das wir uns mischen haben.
Zumindest für Jason gab es das mal
ab 100 Tabelle gesehen.
Wenn ich jetzt drüber rede, müssen wir das in den Short-Rats packen.
Wo einer
verglichen hat und dann so eine Matrix
aufgebaut hat. Das sind so Features
und Ad-Corner-Cases, die
unterstützt werden müssen. Und dann gab es
sogar noch Color-Coding mit
welche Form von Quirk
kommt jetzt hierbei raus, weil du hast manchmal auch
Unstüglichkeiten, wo Sachen falsch interpretiert
werden können. Und dann gibt es halt ein Set von Libraries, die das so
interpretieren und ein Set von Libraries, die das so
interpretieren. Gibt es welche, die das unterstützen, nicht unterstützen,
sondern abstürzen und so weiter.
Ja, aber solche Inconsistencies,
irgendwie mit diesen Inconsistencies-Dielen, ist halt immer
scheiße. Also bei mir am nächsten
wenn man diese Advanced-Visor aus Jamel rausschmeißt,
was wahrscheinlich nicht mehr drin ist, ein neues Jamel hat,
was dann ein bisschen abgespeckter
ist und nutzbar, und dann
kann man damit gut arbeiten. Was aber noch kaputter
ist und noch viel, viel lustiger, ist
das Package-Manifest-Format von
Swift. Das ist ja
Swift, und das wird sich...
Anfang fand ich das eigentlich eine ganz nette Idee.
Was für die ist das? Deine Manifest-Datei
für ein Swift-Projekt, also für ein Swift-Open-Source-Projekt,
in Anführungsstrichen, also für ein, wenn du
das Swift an sich nutzt, ohne
macOS, iOS, Projekte drumherum,
dann hast du eine Package.swift
und die ist geschrieben in Swift
und da hast du ein PackageStruct
und das hat ein Dependencies
Property und das ist ein Array
von Package-Objekten
und die haben halt
eine URL und eine Version
und das geht halt, weil Swift
als interpretierte Sprache hat.
Das wird halt sowieso mit ausgewertet.
Das Beschissene daran aber ist, das hat letztens
darauf hingewiesen, der
Regex-Ident Vincent Esche,
falls ihr das zufällig hören sollte.
Anfangs dachte ich, das ist eine witzige Idee.
Das Kaputte daran ist,
das ist eine Sprache,
mit der kannst du quasi alles tun.
Also es ist Turing-vollständig und wird halt ausgewertet
zur Build-Zeit,
zur Confirme-Zeit. Und wenn du halt zum Beispiel
mit Sudo dein Kram gebaut hast,
warum auch immer, dann hast du halt,
was immer in deiner Package-Swift steht, mit Sudo
ausgeführt. Wenn du Dependencies reinziehst, dann wird auch
deren Package-Swift mit Sudo ausgeführt.
Deshalb wurde jetzt, nachdem das Swift-Team
darauf hingewiesen wurde, erstmal gesendboxt,
aber sagen wir mal, du hast aus irgendeinem Grund da keine Ahnung,
eine Endlosschleife oder irgendeine Blocking-Operation drin,
dann geht dein Bildprozess kaputt
und läuft nie wieder.
Aber das ist ein Problem, was du in der
Ruby-Welt auch schon seit...
Deine Jam-Spec-Dateien
sind auch bloß Ruby-Skripte.
Und das ist nicht mal so, dass sie da
Hashes reinschreiben
und Maps und Arrays,
sondern da sind auch
Funktionsaufrufe drin, wo da plötzlich
du und ein Lambda drinstehen
hast, was dein Konfigurationsobjekt
annimmt, modifiziert und wieder zurückgibt.
Fühlt es zu irgendwelchen Security-Wunabilities?
Gibt es ja irgendwelche...
Bestimmt genug, ja.
Ich meine, wenn du so du Bundle-Install
aufrufst, dann läuft das Ding halt mit gut.
Der Bundle
stand ja auch mit Ruby und dort kannst du ja dann
in Backticks beliebig und
ungefähr
R-R-R-F-Slash.
Ja, genau.
Es gibt eventuell
einen Modus von Ruby,
ich spekuliere jetzt,
sagen wir es mal so, es wäre sinnvoll, wenn es das gäbe.
Mich würde es nicht wundern, wenn es das gibt.
Mich würde es auch nicht wundern, dass es das nicht gibt.
Wenn es einen speziellen Modus von Ruby gibt,
wo du nur eine bestimmte eingeschränkte Funktionen
zum Verrast würde, zum Beispiel keinen Exec machen kannst.
Das dachte ich jetzt in diesem Moment auch.
Und ich könnte mir auch gut vorstellen, dass es einfach die Jump-Reile
in der DSL ist, die gar nicht alles auswerbet.
Ja, das ist ja
der gute Stil bei Ruby,
dass du für jeden Scheiß in der DSL baust,
der auf Ruby basiert.
Deswegen würde es mich halt nicht wundern,
das ist ein ganz normales Ruby, was da interpretiert wird.
Es kann halt sein, dass es ein eingeschränktes
Ruby ist.
Also,
das Ruby-Experte, schreibt uns das mal bitte in die Kommentare,
die mich wirklich interessieren.
Schade, dass ich das jetzt erst
drei Wochen die antworten. Welche Kommentare?
Wir haben keine Kommentare.
Wir haben Kommentare auf Soundcloud
mit genau einem Kommentator, der uns
mittlerweile vier Kommentare geschrieben hat,
Herr Jörg,
und wir bisher noch überhaupt nicht drauf eingegangen sind.
Was hat denn Herr Jörg so geschrieben?
In der letzten Folge hat er uns
eben Dinge korrigiert, soweit ich weiß.
Ach so, ja.
Checker, diese Folge ist übrigens wieder
Joktel.
Genau, das Diaspora hat tatsächlich mit Mongo angefangen,
nicht CouchDB. Können wir hier richtig
stellen. Danke Jörg. Ach so, das hätte ich
euch auch sagen können. MongoDB ist übrigens
das Snapchat der Datenbank.
Nee, das Diaspora mit Mongo angefangen hat.
Hast du nicht darüber gesprochen letzte Woche?
Letzte Woche.
Das kann sein, ja.
Kann ich mich gerade nicht mehr erinnern, aber die hatten
mega Stress, davon wegzubekommen.
zu kommen. Weil man auch eigentlich nur ein besseres Caches
und keine richtige Datenbank in meinen Augen.
Ja.
Was hat er noch geschrieben?
Overheard Language, Dollar Language
is faster C, you cannot be faster
than the computer. Ich bin mir echt
nicht ganz sicher, was genau
er hat. Es gibt glaube ich
einen Blogpost, der hieß
you cannot be faster than
the computer.
Achso, war das bezogen auf das
CS Coffee Script für Assembler?
Ja, klasse. Also ich meine,
Steiger hat ja auch gesagt,
welche Sprache war es?
Vortrag
grundsätzlich schneller ist als C
und das stimmt eigentlich nur,
wenn du
High-Performance-Computing-Bereiche
Ja, wenn du Matrix-Multiplikationen
auspasst.
Die Aussagen, das ist mir auch aufgefallen,
dass die Folge nochmal durchgehört hat,
dass halt Performance nur
im High-Performance-Bereich interessant ist.
Wir haben gerade dieses Thema
Elektron durch. Performance ist halt
wirklich für Nutzer, dass du nicht
schreiend davonrennst.
Es gab diese eine Folge. Wer von euch hat
Halt & Catch Fire gesehen? Ja, ich.
Halt & Catch Fire, sehr in Empfehlung.
Super, super geile
Computerserie.
So ein bisschen wie Silicon Valley
plus Ernst und in den 80ern.
Ja, genau. Die History der Computerentwicklung.
Und es gab einen signifikanten
Moment. Die bauen
einen PC-kompatiblen
Rechner, einen IBM-kompatiblen
Rechner nach und müssen dazu
auch das DOS, was da drauf läuft, komplett
selber implementieren und irgendwann zu einem Zeitpunkt
dann nachweisen, dass sie es nicht abgeschrieben haben.
Und ein
wirklich signifikanter
Punkt in der Entwicklung war, dass sie
diese, ich weiß gar nicht, wie diese Schnelle hieß,
die Reaktionszeit unter
eine bestimmte
Grenze gedrückt haben, das war nämlich unter
200 Millisekunden, dass der
als Benutzer wirklich das Gefühl hast,
dass es fast instantan ist, dass du draufdrückst
und was sofort passiert. Und das ist echt
extrem wichtig.
Ich habe diese kleine, peckige
Kommandozahlenanwendung,
die ich für das ASCII gebaut habe, von Ruby
nach Rust portiert. Das hat es für einen Effekt, es ist 15 Mal
schneller. Das macht es. Es macht nicht viel.
Aber wenn ich auf Enter drücke, möchte ich nicht
bis 3 zählen können, bis der mir eine Bildschirmsseite
Texte ausgedruckt hat.
Da hat der gerade mal einen alten Podcast, auch so eine uralte Story
aus der Apple-Welt gehört,
dass Steve Jobs da unglaublich
viel Wert drauf gelegt hat, dass niemals,
egal was passiert, egal wie das System einfriert,
der Mauszeiger darf niemals einfrieren.
Der muss sich immer bewegen können, damit der Nutzer nicht das Gefühl hat,
der Rechner lässt sich im Stich.
Erstaunlicherweise ist es auch bei Linux
immer so, dass der Mauszeiger, egal wie eingefroren
dein System sich noch bewegen lässt, weil
der einfach an der Stelle vom X-Server implementiert
ist.
Bei Windows leckt der teilweise sogar.
Würde es sogar so weit gehen.
Ich habe das ja auch gebraucht.
Bei Windows geht das auch. Also dein Rechner friert ein,
dein Mauszeiger-Cursor
bewegt sich Ast rein.
Und meine Funktion ist einfach,
dass der Maus zur Kursor,
also das ist echt alt, schon wieder vor dem Krieg,
dass der Maus
Interrupt und die Service-Routine,
die dahinter hängt, irgendwie direkt
in den Grafikkartentreiber reingeht und
dieses Splitting, was Hendrick vorhin erwähnt hat,
mit irgendwelchen Text-Tons,
genauso mit diesem Maus-Cursor macht und den einfach
verschiebt. Zack, das macht die Grafikkarte.
Das braucht keinen wirklichen CPU-Handesteller.
Aber es ist egal, ob das Betriebssystem
komplett festgefahren ist an der Stelle.
Wenn ich die Maus bewege, wird die Grafik
gerade angewiesen, diesen Mauskursor oder irgendwo anders
hinzuschieben.
So könnte ich mir das vorstellen.
Das wird einfach nur unterbrochen,
wenn dein Betriebssystem sauber arbeitet.
Aber wenn es das nicht tut,
dann wird es in so einer Notfallmodus geschaltet.
Nur
hatte ich jetzt noch einen anderen Gedanken.
You can't be faster as the computer,
but you can be smarter.
Ich muss nämlich an den Herrn John Carmack denken,
und das stimmt auch nicht, weil es nicht von ihm ist,
an diesen ganz verrückten
In-Below-Square-Route-Befehl,
den er damals in Quake 3 eingebaut hat,
der schneller war als die Hauptimplementierung.
Das war eine geile Sache.
Ja, es kommt nicht von ihm, es kommt aus der Zeit.
Er hat in Quake
eine Wurzelberechnung eingebaut,
die schneller ist als die Hauptimplementierung
in Software.
Er hat in Software eine Funktion geschrieben,
die die Quadratswurzel
das Inverse, der in der Quadratkurzel
schneller berechnen konnte,
als der Prozessor es eigentlich
berechnen konnte. Und das basiert aber
auf,
nicht auf seinem Wissen, sondern das basiert auf
einem Typen, der bei Atari gearbeitet
hat und das dort beobachtet hat.
Und die Funktion ist auch nur
eine Annäherung. Das heißt,
es stimmt nicht bis auf die letzte
Nachkammerstelle. Aber der Punkt ist, wenn ich
einfach damals, Quick Light, das waren halt
Super-VGA-Zeiten, so 1024,
67, 68 Pixel auf dem Display,
Da hat das einfach gereicht, wenn es auf sechs Nachkommastellen
bestimmt hat.
Da kannst du auch mit
Float bei Pixeln
arbeiten, weil ob das nur
ein paar Kommastellen daneben ist,
und das siehst du dann auch irgendwann nicht.
Das richtig Coole an dieser Funktion ist, wenn man sich die noch mal
anschauen möchte, vielleicht taucht es dann
mit den Journals auf,
ist, dass
er dort von einem Eingabewert,
der ein Integer ist, auf
Float castet und irgendwelche
ganz kruden
Bit-Schiebe-Geschichten
veranstaltet, um im Prinzip
so eine Art Näherung zu bekommen,
an die Quadrat-Fort zu funktionieren.
Das ist unglaublich. Das ist dreimal
so schnell, wie die CPU das berechnen könnte.
Also eine schöne Sache, was Maus-Cursor
angeht, ist noch
javier.xyz
slash control user cursor.
Das gab es auch irgendwie auf Hackernues,
wie man den Maus-Cursor hackt. Ich habe jetzt hier
diesen roten Punkt in der Mitte und ich versuche
mit dem Maus-Cursor da hin zu gehen und je nähere ich
mich an, umso mehr merke ich, dass das
langsamer wird und plötzlich
da gibt es ein zweites Beispiel, das ist jetzt Repel
dann gibt es das zweimal
ein bisschen sinnlos, da gibt es witzigerweise Attract
ich bewege meine Maus in einer geraden Linie
an diesem roten Punkt vorbei und sie wird angezogen
der ist blau
aber der
cheatet, der blendet
deinen Kursor aus und den Kursor, den der in der Webseite
anzeigt, ist einfach eine Grafik
die das dann macht
müssen wir in die Show Notes mit reinpacken
mixed
Repel and Detract.
Und das ist super schön.
Das fällt dir aber auf Linux auf,
weil da, wenn du dann drüber gehst,
ändert sich das Maus-Theme.
Das bist du aber als Linux-Sutzer
so ein bisschen gewohnt, weil egal,
abhängig davon, ob deine Anwendung jetzt mit GTK
oder mit Qt gebaut, das ändert sich eh
dein Maus-Theme-Stell.
Oder ob es ein natives X-Con-Groß hat
von so einem fettes Kreuz.
Oh mein Gott.
Ja, haben wir es langsam, oder?
prinzipiell
wir müssen mal schauen, wie wir Kommentare
irgendwie umsetzen, wir werden wahrscheinlich
viele kriegen, aber es wäre schön, irgendeine Möglichkeit zu haben
im Zweifelsfall könnt ihr uns
auf den Kanälen, die wir
am Ende noch erwähnen, anschreiben
so, jetzt ist unser Podcast vorbei
was sollen sich denn die Leute jetzt als nächstes anhören
wenn jetzt gleich die
schienisch in Panik, oh Gott, der Podcast ist vorbei
ich habe noch, ich sitze im Bus und ich bin
immer noch nicht zu Hause, was mache ich mir als nächstes an
ein Podcast, der
neu ist, also es gibt quasi eine
Folge und eine kurze Nullnummer, ist
der Podcast von dem Ben,
den ich vorhin schon genannt habe, und Dominik,
auch das Dom, der heißt
Hallo Swift, ist ein deutscher Swift-Podcast, ist ganz
neu und
ihr schaut mal rein,
vielleicht ist es was für euch,
bestimmt. Das sind so Leute aus Dresden, die du auch
bestätigst. Ben ist aus Dresden, wo Dominik
herkommt, ich glaube Düsseldorf, ich bin mir gar nicht mehr sicher.
Reden die auch über Schwalbe?
Bisher nicht.
Ein anderer Podcast auch für nicht so technische Leute
und eventuell für Lokalpatrioten.
Oh Gott, nee, das Wort Patrioten.
Für Leute, die sich für Kultur in Dresden interessieren,
ist der Podcast, ich hoffe, ich spreche es richtig aus, Jardin.
Ich habe mir bis jetzt leider erst die erste Folge angehört.
Der ist von Pharma Bub, einer Säherin hier aus Dresden,
die an einer Musikhochschule studiert.
An der HBK oder nicht?
Nein, an der Musikhochschule.
Die Hochschule für Musik.
Die Hochschule für Bildung Kürzel, HBK.
Nein, die Hochschule für Musik
haben wir ja von Weber.
Die hat eine Abkürzung, die fällt mir gerade nicht ein.
Und die interviewt
eigentlich nur ihre Kommilitonen.
Aber halt Musiker,
die ein bisschen deren Vorgeschichte
warum sie sich dazu entschieden haben,
Musik hier zu studieren.
Das ist eigentlich
das Schema ist auch,
Wir treffen uns mal bei mir in der Küche und reden
über einen Kaffee über unser Leben.
Das ist eigentlich ganz schön.
Vor allem, wenn man die Musiker, die da
interviewt werden, regelmäßig in der Tonne
sieht.
Das klingt irgendwie nicht so wie das, was du meinst.
Tonne ist ein Laden.
So, die Tonne.
Für Leute, die nicht aus Dresden kommen.
Die Tonne ist, ich meine,
der Jazz-Club-Tonne.
Was quasi der Studenten-Club von der
Musikhochschule ist.
Ein anderer Podcast, den ich noch kurz mit
ansprechen möchte, damit wir wieder ein paar Podcast-Empfehlungen haben.
Den höre ich jetzt seit ein paar Wochen.
Der heißt GM World of the Week
für Game Master World of the Week.
In erster Linie vor allem...
Word of the Week.
Wort der Woche.
In erster Linie ein Podcast vor allem für Fans
und Spieler von Dungeons & Dragons.
Aber ich persönlich
habe bisher einmal
gespielt und finde aber
die Welt ziemlich cool.
Aber der geht in so viel mehr Bereiche.
Der macht einen riesigen
ein Haken, der in dem Spiel spielt. Er spielt natürlich
immer ein bisschen auf Lungens und Dragons ein, aber wenig.
In den letzten Folgen spricht er über
diverse Metall-Elemente,
Legierungen und Elemente, die halt gerade aus der Fantasie
ein bisschen bekannt sind vom Namen, wie
Adamant oder Orichalkum, der natürlich auch
Deutsch heißt, aber dass die halt alle
historisch irgendwo einen Kontext haben und dieses
Orichalkum zum Beispiel, das wurde in
Omeras Idiot schon erwähnt und
lange war es gedacht, das ist einfach nur irgendein
Made-up-Scheiß, den es nicht gab und tatsächlich wurde das
irgendwann entdeckt und, sorry, dass ich es hier gerade gespoert habe,
Weil es einfach eine Legierung aus Messing, Zink und noch irgendwas ist.
Ist nicht Messing schon irgendwie Zink?
Egal.
Kupfer und Zink.
Kupfer und Zink und irgendwie Charcoal ist da noch mal drin.
Und das ist das, was es tatsächlich mal gab.
Und das war lange nicht bewusst.
Mythen und Krams und unglaublich Wohnt.
Bevor du den ganzen Podcasts vorausnimmst.
Ihr könnt das euch annehmen.
Spaßig.
Zieht es mal rein.
Das ist witzig.
Gut, dann rollen wir es jetzt ab.
Eine Sache noch.
Nächste Woche kommt das Wochenende
Podcast hoffentlich bis dahin
draußen.
Am 29. und 30.
falls ihr Dresdner seid, ist das Mobile Camp
hier in der Fakultät Informatik
der TU. Ein Barcamp
für in erster Linie Mobilentwickler
und alles, was irgendwie
mit Apps zu tun hat, muss sie kein Entwickler
sein, aber ihr könnt einfach nur interessiert sein.
Oder ihr könnt Entwickler sein, wenn nichts mit Apps zu tun haben?
Prinzipiell auch.
Klar, also generell für alle Interessierten.
ist eine richtig coole Sache, es gibt immer noch Tickets
die ganze Schose ist kostenlos
es gibt kostenlose T-Shirts
für alle die kommen, es gibt kostenloses Essen
und unglaublich coole Talks und ich will dieses Jahr auch
endlich mal einen Talk halten und habe mir da was vorgenommen
und wenn ihr mich über Dinge reden hört
die ich noch nicht öffentlich sage, für die Falle
ich es nicht vorbereitet bekomme
dann kommt vorbei
also das Datum ist der?
29. und 30.
Sonntag und Sonntag
also hoffentlich habt ihr jetzt
denkt euch nicht, ah scheiße, das war gestern,
sondern cool,
das ist morgen.
Ihr werdet uns da definitiv antreffen
und uns zu unserem wunderbaren Podcast gratulieren.
Okay, das war's.
Vielen Dank, liebe Zuhörer, dass ihr
so lange zugehört habt.
Wir sind
akronomisierbar mit
Julian, Hendrik und
Steiger. Wir sind nicht nur
akronomisierbar, wir sind auch
abonnierbar.
Abonnierbar.
Und zwar auf iTunes,
bislang noch auf Soundcloud,
aber nicht mehr lange und mysteriöserweise
bald auf hoffentlich unserer eigenen Webseite.
Auf FÜND und überall,
wo ihr Podcasts findet.
Ihr habt uns ja auf dem Badischen gefunden.
Für Feedback und Fragen
und Glückwünsche bitte an
adakonomisierbar auf Twitter.
Ihr könnt übrigens auch nicht schreiben, wenn ihr es nicht könnt.
Wunder ich nicht.
Wir brauchen grundsätzlich mindestens drei Anläufe, um akonomisierbar
zu schreiben.
Du bist auch auf Twitter?
Ich bin auf Twitter, ihr könnt mich anschreiben unter
at hoodie-de.
Ich bin at Kilian K.O.E., ein L.
Und ich bin
unter at Steiger
mit 9 E zu erreichen.
S-T-E-I-G-E-A, genau.
Also das war Folge 004
von Akronomisierbar. Vielen lieben Dank
fürs lange Zuhören und
jetzt kommt der nächste neue Podcast
in 3, 2,
1.